here. Oh, no, don't take it all down, Gina. Smooth, smooth. All right, so my name is Nick. I'm the
president here at Uvalux. I won the coin toss, which means that I get to give today's presentation
to kick off today's expo. I can tell you that this room is full of cheerleaders
because I can tell about all the love and all the positive energy that's here today.
I'm really glad that so many of us were able to come together and huddle
together under the lights, tanning lights, dad joke all around. I'm still good. Oh, yeah, put it down.
I'm totally fine. So people can huddle together under the lights to share ideas, gain knowledge,
and hopefully learn something good today. So you can help you call good plays and help you
build your business or career to help you score big. Nobody. No, nothing. All right. So I'm sorry
for my speech is full of all these bad puns, much like the Bills Chief game was
full of all the bad ref calls. That's for Maggie. Now seeing that this is the
only time Elaine and Caitlin have allowed me to speak, I'm
gonna hog the mic. So let me introduce to you our offensive line. This group of
people continue to carry the ball and drive the industry forward with new
products and new technologies. So our vendors here today, our starting lineup
up, and I want big rounds of applause. From Indianapolis, Indiana, the team from New Sunshine,
Jason, Jessica, and Rachel. From Tampa, Florida, the team from Devoted Creations,
Louis, Michaela, and Alex. From Podunk, Southern Indiana, Illinois, sorry, wrote that wrong. From
Podunk, her words, Southern Illinois, we have Gina from Sun Evolutions. All the way from Detroit,
We have Hans Bolt from Michigan with JK, big round of applause.
From Nashville, he's number one in our hearts.
From Sunless Inc., Jacob's in the back, everybody, big round of applause.
Representing our industry, we all know him, from the JCTA, Steve Gilroy.
All the way, our import from Holland with Ultrasun, everybody say good morning to Tim.
And the man from the metaverse, our Google guy, is David.
Where's David?
over in the back so they say that defense wins championships your
defensive team here today is team you've looks so if you want somebody to lean on
protect you that's who you go to all of our you've Lux team was walking around
in referee jerseys today if you need anything whatsoever if they don't know
the answer they'll find someone who does so please find everybody or anybody if
you need them in the referee jersey now I can't intro them all because we'll be
be here for a long time. Most of you guys know everybody who's here. There are two new faces
within the group. First of all, our West Coast import, who's coming up from the minors, because
truthfully, the West Coast is the majors, right? Let's be honest. She won a sales contest to be
here today. So everybody say hi to Julie. And then our newest draft choice ran a very successful
Sunless business. She was an educator with Sunna. She'll be running the Sunna booth display.
everybody say good morning to Denise. Oh she's right over here. Now I mean this the
most important player on the field they say is the quarterback. Now our defensive
team and our offensive line are all here to protect and support and look after
the quarterback. The quarterback today guys is you guys. We wouldn't be here if
it wasn't for the drive and the energy that we get from our salon owners and our
employees and our managers. It is absolutely absolutely phenomenal. You
You guys are the one that drive this industry.
So from the bottom of our hearts, thank you so much for being here.
Big round of applause for all of you.
All right, to a little bit of business at hand.
We did call an audible.
I'm not done yet.
We did call an audible today on the structure of the expo.
What we wanted was more movement, more energy, and more information that was more pertinent to you guys and your business.
So we split the entire group into two groups.
Room A is focused on product knowledge and heavily weighted towards more employees.
Room B is focused on professional workshops for owners and managers.
If you're wearing a white wristband, you go into room B.
Everybody with me?
Okay.
If you're wearing a white wristband, you go into room B, which is more focused for owners and managers.
Now, everybody say hi to Daniel.
Daniel and his team will be floating around today.
They are recording both rooms.
So, if you want to go back and look at and review the plays of today,
If you miss something in one room, it will be recorded.
All the links will be live on uvalux.com.
We'll share that after the event, all right?
Lastly, unlike my 49ers, we're all winners here today, all right?
So there's gift prizes all day, given out in both rooms.
We all very lovely enjoyed mimosas today.
That was courtesy from Devoted Creations and the team, so a big round of applause.
everybody gets a big bag of goodies at the end of the day, right? So feel free to enjoy that.
And afterwards, after the event, we're going to have a tailgating party sponsored by the team
for new sunshine. So to break out of this huddle, I swear I'm almost done. To have a little fun,
what I want you guys to do is turn around amongst you guys, turn into a group, put your hands in,
and on three, we're going to do sunshine, right? One, two, three, sunshine. You guys got me?
All right, so let's find each other, find groups, hands in the middle, hands in the middle, and on three.
One, two, three, sunshine!
All right, let's go have some fun.
Do we need some more chairs?
There's a couple over here, right in the back.
Okay.
Welcome, everyone.
Thank you all for coming.
We really appreciate it.
I love seeing a room like this.
My name is Elaine Bridget and I'm the Director of Sales and Marketing here.
Today we've got a really packed day for you guys.
This is a very informative presentation.
I want you guys to raise your hand, ask questions, give us some suggestions when we're talking.
I want us to collaborate together and really get the ideas streaming, okay?
Okay, whether you are an entrepreneur, a business leader, or a sales professional,
this workshop is designed to help you unlock new growth opportunities and drive the success of our
industry. Today, we're going to be exploring strategies to enhance your business development,
increasing your revenue, right, and strengthen your market positioning. I want you guys to all
all take a look at who's beside you. Look around the room. You guys are all here, and you're one
step ahead of your competitors to strengthen your position in the market. We'll dive into topics
such as merchandising, leveraging industry associations, and implementing staff incentives.
We'll also discuss sales strategies, marketing techniques, manufacturer loyalty programs, and the
the power of embracing memberships
to grow your bottom line.
This session, like I said, is really interactive.
I wanna hear the ideas, I want you to raise your hands,
and really just join us in collaborating together.
Each of you are receiving an actionable item
in front of you, those are for you.
Write some notes, take them back with you,
and I want you guys to look at this
over the next six months and go, you know what?
I'm gonna implement something from today what is it circle back and we're gonna
reach out to you and ask you hey what did you take from that that day what did
you implement how did you grow your business okay I want you to make a
commitment to yourself your staff in the industry so without further ado let's go
ahead and get started I'm going to introduce Leanne come on up Lee
everybody say hi to Leanne. Our first presenter, Leanne Tideman, she's been in the industry for
26 years. I've been in the industry for 23. We laughed last night between the two of us.
We've been in the industry 50 years and we're only 25. Whether you're new to the industry or
you're looking to refine your approach, Memberships Made Simple really offers insight, proven
proven strategies, and practical tips to maximize your bottom line.
Leanne, it's all you. Come on up.
All right. Oh, yeah, I guess we're no clicker. Is that what we're doing here?
And you're doing this.
Oh, you guys all have one of these in front of you? Perfect.
Today, when we have our breaks and our lunch, please make sure that you take it to the trade show floor,
visit our vendors and they will stamp or fill out the front for you once it's
complete then you can be entered into our grand prize draw so that will take
place at the end of the day and I believe I believe the grand prize draw
last I heard is a $250 Ticketmaster gift certificate so maybe go to a concert
maybe go to show do something fun sports game whatever works for you all right
Right. Now, who here has a business goal already set for 2026? 2026? 2025? You want to have
something for next year too, but for 2025, you've got business goals. Have you actually written
them down, committed to yourself, some ideas? Ronnie, I believe that. I know you have. I think
most of us have this goal, right? Make more money. Is that what we all want? Make more money.
I'm going to talk to you about one of the ways that I have seen consistently work for salons to make more money.
And I know there's some people here in the room that I have worked with and can attest to having great success.
This is a little bit of food for thought.
So can you raise your hand for me if you currently offer EFTs or memberships in your salon?
Amazing. Amazing. I love that.
How many of you sell minute sessions credits, even if you sell memberships still?
Yeah, it's common, right? As Elaine mentioned, I've been in the industry for 26 years. Not a ton has changed in that time. Even pricing has not really changed much. But one of the things that I want you to think about today is if you had no more revenue across your counter, how much would you owe in services to the clients that have already paid you?
What is your liability to clients today in terms of minutes, sessions, points, etc.?
How long could you operate your business without ever getting a dime?
That's a liability.
That's why memberships have such power.
This is my top five favorite reasons for why you need memberships if you don't already.
And I know many of you have.
There's probably one or two in this room that don't.
And I want you to just kind of think about this.
So asset versus liability.
This, to me, is my number one favorite reason why you need to have memberships in your salon.
Asset versus liability, okay?
If you have recurring revenue from memberships, that is considered an asset to your business.
You have X amount of dollars that you're expecting in your business.
If you have sold minutes, points, sessions, that's a liability.
So when it comes time to putting your business in a position to sell, in a business to get credit,
it. Say you want to upgrade, you want to purchase new equipment. Having recurring revenue acts as an
asset for your business. It's so important to your bottom line. Also recurring monthly revenue
equals predictable cash flow. And we all want predictable cash flow, but it's really, really
nice. And I can tell you, excuse me, one of my first membership made simple customers, I'll never
forget. It was somebody that I knew very well, had been in the industry for some time, left the
the industry, came back and we were chatting and he actually took over a salon and he said to me,
I don't have time to make changes like this. I just, I need to get this place up and going.
And I said, you do need to make this change. You do need to make this change. You need to
put memberships in place. I will help you. We will get this off the ground. We will get this
done for you. And by doing that, he took over in December and he came to one of our barbecue
events and I will never, ever forget. It was July and he walked in the door. I was like,
like, hey, buddy, how's it going? And he stretched his arms up and he goes, good. It's July and I'm
sleeping like a baby. Because he had revenue. He knew that when he put the key in the door,
he had that money coming into his salon. So he felt really good about that. One-time sale for
long-term benefits. You all know, you've been at the counter, you have the conversations with
people. Let's reduce the time that our staff spend at the counter reselling packages. Oh,
oh, you're using your last hand today.
Oh, okay, I get paid on Friday, I'll be back
or what have you, right?
Let's reduce that.
Let's take the time to have memberships in place
so that those sales conversations
become additional products and services.
Budgeted funds versus disposable income.
This is another big one.
And especially with kind of the way things have been lately,
our world is really constantly going up and down,
isn't it?
All sorts of surprises, right?
From COVID on through.
True. But there's a very big difference in how a customer or a client looks at their money.
So if you have an insurance bill or a car payment or a phone bill and that's coming out of your bank account,
you just know that that's coming out of your bank account.
It's not really going to change maybe how you do when you go to the mall on a Friday night.
when you you know your your budgeted income is very very different than your disposable income
and when it comes to tanning most people are using disposable income you have to make them
change that to budgeted income and there's a lot of psychology involved in memberships
there's a lot to to sort of break down but ultimately when somebody is spending budgeted
funds, it's not on their mind as frequently. They are thinking of visits to you as free.
They'll come more often. If they're running on packages and they know it's running low or they're
going to run out, there's a very big difference in how they visit you. And it's in your best
interest to have clients come and see you more often. I know that memberships work because you
have clients that come in very frequently and very infrequently. However, you want clients in your
your door because the more they're in your door the more they're talking about you the more they're
talking about to others about you and the more products and services that you can add on lastly
increasing client retention so this very much goes to the psychology of things again and if somebody
feels like they are a belonging to you a member of yours they're much less likely to see your
competitors advertising they actually take much less stock of that because they instantly go oh
oh, I already have my membership.
So they just don't even look
because they feel like they're belonging.
And it's up to you what you make belonging feel like.
I'll talk a little bit more about that in a sec.
So, because so many of you here have memberships,
I really wanted to talk to you about how you're growing them.
What are you doing?
Have you evolved?
I just had a great conversation in the hallway
with somebody who I sat down
and we went through a membership program years ago.
And he said to me, I've evolved it, I've changed it.
And I said, great, I'm really glad to hear that.
because it's not a one and done. It's never a one and done. You always have to be moving forward.
You always have to be moving that goalpost and figuring out what's next. So in order to grow
your EFTs, can anyone tell me some of the strategies that you guys might have? Anybody
doing something that they think is amazing for gaining memberships? When clients buy minute
packages, you offer them additional minutes. Okay, that's great. That's added value, right? So we're
We're talking about if you currently are selling memberships, how can you add value so that your
clients will level up? Yeah. A free lotion if they sign up. That's wonderful. So with our
Memberships Made Simple program, one of the things that we offer at Uvalux is a value added package
that you can purchase, that you can then give to your clients as a sign up. And that for them is
is added value. So if they see that on the counter and they see, well, I can get a $70 worth of
product for signing up, that's one reason to sign up, right? So value added. Offering referral
incentives. So do any of you offer a Bring a Friend campaign? Yeah, Tan Republic, I was going
to say, is very popular in the U.S. It's very popular in the U.S. The Bring a Friend campaign,
pain many people on their top tier of membership will allow their clients to bring somebody with
them to tan and it really doesn't hurt the bottom line now you don't have to do it all the time
you can do it seasonally you can do it as a monthly special you can do it in so many different
ways but it's a really great way to add so if I know that I love to tan my husband doesn't come
come very often, but I want him to come more often, I might level up in my memberships knowing
that I can drag him along once in a while, right? It would mean a lot to me to do that. And I might
be more likely to get them there, but I'm going to spend more on a higher level membership in
order to do that. Lunchtime limited promotion. Yeah, go ahead. You've got, yeah, that's great.
yeah and they can pay an upgrade right did everyone hear that so they do a friendly friday
you can bring in your friend they get access to your your lowest tier and you can upgrade them
that's wonderful did you have something okay we haven't talked to you yeah you can level down
Yeah. Yes. Yep. Often people. Wonderful. Added value. Yeah. That's exactly where I was going
to go with that. Discounting is very popular. It works, but I love added value. I love bundling.
I love, you know, one of the things that I would say, upselling with add-ons, encourage
premium product purchases.
So let's take one of your higher end products, sit down, figure out what your margin is on
that, okay?
Figure out what your margin is on that and figure out how can you add value?
What can you do here?
So maybe you can contact your rep and say, you know what, is there a product that you
have available that I could maybe buy as a special deal if it's a volume buy?
And maybe you can bundle something.
thing. So that's a great way to add value versus discounting. You've got to give them something
better. You've got to re-carret them. So what you might do, and one of the things that works well
with memberships is grandfathering. Grandfathering pricing, grandfathering special things, and I
always consider it like Fight Club. Nobody talks about Fight Club, but it's still there. So when I
Oftentimes when I work with a salon and we move them over from what they're doing today
to memberships, you know what?
There's a client that's been coming in for 20 years and they always buy the same package
and they always do the thing.
Don't upset the apple cart.
Let them keep doing that.
But every new customer coming in gets this pricing and sees only this pricing.
So you can continue and you can grow forward.
So you're going to tell these people, you're like, hey, we're not doing that anymore.
more that's a super secret and you are special and it's what a great reason to stay connected
okay improving member experiences special perks for EFT clients extras for the top tier levels
okay anyone have anything you've you mentioned you're discounting anyone doing anything else
for their top tier clients yeah Ronnie complimentary lotion storage that's fabulous
if you've got the space for it that's wonderful yeah did you have an answer no it was just for
the previous one so for us to try to get es really working yeah offer a free spray tan yeah
their membership wave um normally there is a fee to sign up yeah wonderful and then we ended up
getting a few people signing up and nobody ever used the spray tan yeah yeah so you get people in
so and that's just it memberships are ever evolving right they're they're always moving
moving along and you have like I say the average membership is going to last four to five months
okay if you ask them for a three-month commitment they're purchasing today they're committing to two
months following on average you'll get four to five months out of people that means you have
to keep selling you have to get them going up to a higher tier yes what do you say to them
we can talk we can absolutely sit down and talk um you're close to the ontario office so we can
yeah angela or i at any time we can sit down and chat with you and really kind of work through
what that would look like based on your experience how am i for time i don't have my timer i'm okay
um so how do you grow your efts use loyalty rewards who here rewards their best clients
clients anyone yes yes yes yes we all want rewards we all want to feel good so maybe you reward
somebody at the sixth month after their membership maybe it's something small maybe it's a you know
a bottle of a tan extender but at a year let's work out how much that client spent with you
because maybe throwing them a hundred dollar gift card wouldn't be a bad idea I know you love to go
Go to wherever, Starbucks, Coach, wherever you think that, you know, you know something
about them.
That makes people feel special, okay?
Focus on digital marketing.
We have a great talk this afternoon about digital marketing, so I'm not going to get
into it much, but if you don't have an e-blast or social posts currently, I want you to include
memberships in those posts.
If you have an e-blast, let's have a members-only section.
Let's have people have FOMO, right?
You want them to feel like they're missing out on something.
Members only.
Did you have somebody back here?
No.
Leveraging member testimonials and reviews.
That's another one.
That's a big one.
You want people talking about your salon.
Encourage people to talk about your salon.
Throw up a QR code on your desk.
See these right here?
We're going to leverage you guys today.
We want you to use this QR code and tell us how we're doing.
and you should do the same with your clients
because I know personally
and I'm sure that you guys probably feel the same
when I shop, I rely on reviews.
If somebody doesn't have reviews,
I am much less likely to use their services.
Partner with local businesses,
cross promote, community events.
If you are not out in your community being seen,
you're missing out.
There's a little bit of outreach
that can go along with being,
it doesn't have to be a tanning event
for you to participate.
but maybe you can bring something cool to the event.
Get your staff organized, make them a team,
make it a fun outing for them,
but get out into your community and be seen
because people do business with people they know, okay?
Are you maximizing your membership opportunities?
New equipment, new equipment, what are you doing?
How are you changing your salon?
Even if you're rearranging, even if you're picking up,
setting your goal to have one new piece of equipment,
that's how you level up members I can't tell you the number of conversations that I have had with
salons and they will say to me well I'm going to do this mix and if you're loaded on the bottom end
if you have all 20 minute beds you're not going to sell the higher end so what's really cool about
memberships is your custom your custom from your competitor down the road you can have a salon
next door to you and what you offer is different than what they offer on a membership so the goal
with members is always to add the most possible value to the highest possible level and that's
how you hook people amen amen kate include value added services add exclusive perks like members
events who here does anything just for members how about a sun-kissed soiree or a glow and gather
like how fun would it be to invite only your members into the salon on a friday night i'm
I'm sorry. We're closed to you other folk. It's members only after 7 PM, 7 till 9. We're doing a
special event. Peasants. It's peasants. If you're not a member, you're a peasant. Yes. We're closed
to you guys because we're having mimosas. We're smelling lotions. We're doing free trials and
it's a run of the salon tonight. Like how cool is that? Make people feel special. Include seasonal
upgrades, temporary upgrades available off peak. So I love this and I'm sure you guys do this at
TAN Republic too. Do you offer people the chance to upgrade their membership? So let's say you have
three tiers today or four tiers and you have a level two member, offer them as you get into
to September, September to December, offer them a chance to a lifetime upgrade on their
membership.
So if they're level two and they pay X amount of dollars for $99 in September, they can
upgrade to the end of the year, or maybe they can upgrade permanently and maybe it's $69.
Everybody's got a different math, so I can't put a number on it, but offer upgrades during
slow and off-peak seasons.
maximize. Because guess what? Once Sandy starts tanning in your new vitality bed,
she ain't going back to the 20-minute beauty, right? Retention strategies for current members.
Conduct regular check-ins. Who here calls their customers? Anybody actually reach out and call
a customer? Yes. Yes. You have an AI that does it. Guess what? We're in the land of technology,
right? Reach out and talk to your customers. Call your best customers. Talk to them. Find out how
how they're doing. Tell them you appreciate their business. Write them a handwritten note. It means
the world to people just to be thought of, just to be a part of something. Recognize top clients
with VIP perks, gifts, priority booking. Everybody operates a different business, so I can't pigeonhole
this into one single thing, but there's so, so many ways that you can make people feel special.
what does membership feel like at your salon do you offer free water do you offer extra towels
do you offer our new cooling mist from australian gold you get a spritz when you come out right like
there's so many things that you can do that just makes people feel special yeah ronnie all hell
breaks loose if you candy those beds i worked in a salon for years we always candied the beds
and let me tell you when we ran out of Werther's shit hit the fan right you do
not mess with people's candy does anyone else have any ideas for retention
strategies how am I for time okay let's I want to hear from you guys on the
floor I want to hear what are you doing today that is retaining members that's
growing membership that's allowing you to sell more how are you doing that
ads. Anybody have an awesome idea to share? Yeah. Any new client automatically gets put in.
That's fabulous. Treat people like they're special. Like they are one of a kind.
She'd like to have exclusivity. Don't go there. You want people. Here's a, here's a story. You
want people there because people create tanners. More businesses create more tanners. You just all
have to play together. That's why we're in this room. Cause we will play nice. Yeah.
it's all about the experience you provide so exactly you're providing a clean service you're
providing uh exactly and that makes a world of difference to people so I often hear that
complaint people say well a gym moved in and they're charging nothing for tanning and it's
dirt cheap and you know what guess what the people that want to tan there and that aren't getting the
service level that you provide are not your clients anyway but you know what sometimes happens is a
a salon or a fitness center or somebody who's maybe isn't that upper echelon creates a new
client because it was inexpensive to start, then they come over to you. Yeah. All right. Oh, oh,
Mo. Yes. Yeah. Friendly Fridays. It's amazing. It's amazing. Offering the, the, the, the friend
to tan free makes a big difference. Yes. Oh gosh, no. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So it ends up being like over $14 more than the membership.
Yeah.
So you buy three months.
I pretty much have you hooked.
Yeah.
You may not go for the next one year.
You're going to buy the next three months,
and you're going to buy three months because you're not locked in for 12.
It's all psychological.
There's so much in the psychological.
It's like pricing.
If you keep your pricing at $99 instead of $100, people will spend $99, but they don't want to spend $100.
Definitely.
They don't want to spend $115, but they'll spend $114.99, won't they?
They will, yeah.
So we do this mini-membership, and I would say it's probably 75% successful in talking to permanent clients.
I want to, I want to talk to you because I want you to change all of your members over to that.
I don't want you to try to commit anybody for a year. Nobody knows what they're doing three months
from now. Change evolution. We can do this. We can do great things. Yeah. We're going to talk.
We're going to talk. There's ways to do this. Okay. I want you to take that major commitment
out nobody knows what they're doing in a year everybody's had a shitty experience with a gym
that they've been locked into and they don't go and they end up feeling negative about it
yeah so when you do lock in that membership yeah everything's great they're gonna lock in for either
three months six months or whatever but then after a month card gets declined because they want to
lock into that rate yeah so they will do it for two months that's why we developed our memberships
made simple program we have an awesome company that we work with that we went out and found that
you guys can work with we don't work with them personally we found a company that you guys can
work with it handles that exact thing we recommend that you do no longer than a three-month commitment
first month in-house commitment of two months that's it that's all after that they are free
to cancel because nobody likes to feel confined you will sell way more memberships if it gets
declined then their membership gets gets put on pause most people there are two kinds of people
that will decline a membership people who have an accident and people who are serial and you know
what the serial you're going to weed through them they're minor in the grand scheme of things you'll
make way more on memberships then it's worth even talking about those couple of people who are jerks
we're a little different here in canada yeah we're yeah the canadian banking software is a little
little different so we do have a link that's worked out specifically with sunlink sunlink can
can handle yeah okay yeah so we're we're a little bit more confined in terms of the regulation here
but we that's we actually as uvalax we built that bridge for sunlink to be able to talk to mts so we
could process the memberships as well if you guys have any more questions at all about memberships
I um I'm going to defer to Angela who's in our other room she's taking oh there she is
Angela DeMell is our primary uh rep for memberships made simple so if you have any
questions at all you can reach Angela you can always still reach out to myself I'm always here
I'm always available to chat but I'm not as available as Angela is just because I do have
a little less time in the office okay but we actually I was well that's not
your email address come on ang you've got are you a DeMille okay so she's
she's a DeMille at you've Alex calm how do you not still have your Angela email
do you guys have any more questions about memberships if not I'm going to
introduce one of my dearest friends miss elaine bridget i know that you guys already heard from
her but as she mentioned elaine has got over 24 years of experience in the indoor tanning and
wellness industry elaine is passionate about the expansion of wellness and transformative
benefits of tanning she believes that tanning is wellness enhancing not just appearance but
overall well-being driven by her dedication to health beauty and business growth elaine has
helped countless individuals and businesses thrive by integrating wellness-focused solutions.
Her expertise in industry trends, customer engagement, and innovative business strategies
make her a trusted voice in the field. And she's one of my friends. She's one of my dearest friends.
We've worked together for a long time. We finish each other's thoughts, and I'm really excited to
bring her up to chat about some wellness. Thanks, Alex. Okay, I'm going to fix this
clicker situation, too. Thank you. Okay, the moment of truth, guys. You ready?
Okay. Thank you so much, Leanne. Isn't she amazing? The knowledge in her brain is just
really, really incredible. Thank you. I want to ask you guys a question. How many of you guys
have incorporated wellness into your salon spa? I'm going to ask you one more time. How many of
you guys have incorporated wellness into your salon? I want every single person to put your
your hand up, because tanning is wellness. So one more time. How many of you guys have
incorporated wellness in your salon? Tanning is wellness, right? But there are other wellness
options besides tanning. What do we have? Does anybody have other wellness options besides tanning
in their spa salon. Merv, put your hand up. What do we got? Lisa, what do you have?
All of those things. Excellent. Excellent. That's excellent. Okay, so halo therapy. It's a sauna
with salt therapy. It's amazing, right? We're going to help purify the air. Wave water massage bed.
bed. We're going to have a nice relaxing massage while we're having a bad day. Red light. Red light
LED lay down. UV in conjunction with red and blue light. It's incredible, right? I love selling
wellness into salons. It's my most favorite thing to do. And the reason why it's my most favorite
thing to do is because it was kind of pairs into what Leanne was saying that it allows us
us an opportunity to bring innovation into the salons, put people on memberships, and increase
our price. So many times I'll walk into salons and I'll look at the price and they haven't changed it
in a decade. I want you guys to think about Starbucks or Tim Hortons. The first time you
bought a Tim Hortons coffee, it was a dollar for me. Coffee was a dollar. Now I'm paying $1.85,
right? I want you guys to look at your pricing. If you can do anything this year, look at your
pricing and increase it. If you have to, I have a salon owner on Ontario. I won't say his name,
try to convince him to come out, but he wouldn't. Um, I had a meeting with him in September and
he's brought in a lot of wellness pieces. He's brought in a lot of bigger beds. Um, and he's
doing really well. He's doing phenomenal. Uh, and he brought in memberships, brought in memberships
after we sat down, we had a conversation in September and he incorporated memberships in
November. He said, if you can do anything for your business, I want you to do this. And he was so
worried. He's like, Elaine, he's like, I make so much money in busy season. And he's seen like 300
people a day. He's like, I just can't do it. I'm like, please do me a favor and bring in memberships.
He called me in December and he said to me, he goes, I just want to thank you. I brought in
in memberships and this December, and he's been in the industry for over 20 years. He's like,
this December I made the most money I've ever made in this industry because he brought in
memberships. So everybody write that down on your, on your take, take away. Um, I'm going to talk
today a little bit about cocoons because it is my favorite unit to put into a salon. But I say to
people when they ask me, should I bring in a cocoon? I'm like, you only bring in a cocoon if
you have memberships. If you don't have memberships, that's not your priority
today. Your priority is to get memberships and then bring in a cocoon
because these pieces here are pieces that you utilize to upsell members, to
upsell memberships, right? So now you have an all-access pass and you add the
cocoon to it or a VIP or a platinum membership. Whatever your tiers are,
whatever your marketing is, that's going on your platinum membership and it's
included in that platinum membership. Now that's a free offering in your platinum. So now you're
upgrading people naturally because that's a free offering, right? So we're going to talk about
cocoons. We have one, we're very fortunate. We have one in our office and if I'm having a bad
day or if I've got a headache, I just jump in that thing for 20, 20 minutes to 30 minutes and I feel
fantastic afterwards. The cocoon itself has been revolutionary to our industry
just because it's a nice quick unit to put in. I don't have to have plumbing, I
don't have to have major electrical, it almost fits in every single room. I've
had people put it in their broom closet and it's fit. But why you want to use it?
You want to use it for these reasons and I'm just going to quickly go through it
it. But before I do, can I add a raise of hands who has cocoons in their stores? That's great.
Okay. First reason, weight loss and inch loss. Anybody ever say, no, I'm not interested in that.
I'm interested in that. When you go into the cocoon on high hypothermic heat,
your body after about 20 minutes starts to metabolize fat cells and that's where inch
loss and weight loss start to occur. You see that, right? Do you need to drink a lot of water before
you get in the cocoon? Absolutely. Because water is the delivery system that helps your body sweat
out all the toxins, right? So you can detox as well. So like maybe you've had a few extra drinks
on a Friday night. You wake up Saturday morning, you're not feeling too great. You hop in a cocoon
session. During that session, you might not feel great, but afterwards you feel like a million
bucks. That allows you to get on with your day, right? So detox. It improves your physical fitness
and core strength because it's got workout bands in it. I have the unit here. I want you guys
during the break to take a look at it, jump in it. We'll turn it on. Okay. Uh, improve energy.
It helps increase oxygen at the cellular level, giving you more energy. Okay. We actually have
people too. And in the morning they'll jump in it. If they're having a really hard time regulating
their sleeping patterns. Um, I always suggest to people if they, if they come into my office
and they're like, oh, I feel terrible. I didn't sleep well last night. I'm like, I want you to
take a break today as early as you can. I want you to jump in the cocoon. Your energy levels
will increase and then you'll be able to actually sleep tonight. I guarantee you.
Relaxation. I just need a break. We're go, go, go. We're always on our phones. We have people
coming at you in every single direction. You got Snapchat. You got Instagram messages. You got
got Facebook messages, you got emails, you got text messages, you got phone, right? The amount of
resources people have to get you, it's nice to take that break, right? Wellness. Pain management.
We actually have people that suffer from arthritis that will jump in a cocoon and they'll be
essentially pain-free for 24 hours. And it's going to help tone and tighten. Who doesn't want that?
come on come on the features of the technology so it's got an LED touch
screen you'll be able to see that you'll be able to separate it depending on what
they want so you'll be able to sell it to different types of customers somebody
coming in that just needs a power nap right maybe you're in a downtown core
and you've got people that want to jump in on their lunch it's great unit to
allow them to come in and have a quick little snooze they just need to relax
right they want weight management right they want that high hypothermic heat
wellness and then fitness do a core workout while you're in there it is hot
it can get hot you can put it on low settings but you want to sweat when you
get in this it gets up to 194 degrees okay it's got the fit system so the
resistance bands that allow you to do the core workout vibrating massage
Massage. Amazing. So yeah, go ahead. Um, it is in the, I think it is 320. Yeah. We had this
conversation. Didn't we, Alex? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So it's pretty, it's pretty good. I had a guy that
came in, he was, um, a bodybuilder. He was probably about six foot and he's like, I won't
fit. I'm like, I just want you to get in it and see. And it was a tight, like around his shoulders,
shoulders, but he fit in it no problem because your head's outside of it too, right? And that's
the one thing I love about it. It's an infrared sauna, right? When I go in an infrared sauna
and I can maybe last 15 minutes, I got to get out. If I'm at high heat, I can't breathe in there,
but I need to be in that a lot longer so that my body starts to metabolize the fat cells, right?
So with the cocoon, my head is outside of the unit and it's got airflow so I can breathe
breathe night easily in there with some cool airflow. So then I can stay in for a half an
hour. This machine, you can stay in for, for up to 90 minutes. I don't suggest it. I'll go through
that in a second. It's got red light therapy through it as well. How many of you guys have had
an influx of people calling or coming into the salon asking if you've had, if you have red light
therapy. How many of you guys offer red light therapy? You guys are, this is actually a really
good room. This is great, but it's, it's huge right now. It's trending. We need to get ahead
of that. Bring it in, bring in people that, you know, maybe, maybe they haven't come to see you
in a long time. Now you can offer them something or a reason to come back and see how much you've
evolved and how much the space has changed. Right. I actually have, um, like it's, it's one
one of the biggest things in Hollywood right now. Everybody's looking for a red light machine.
Okay. So red light, it's got the cool facial air aroma system. So you can actually put in any kind
of essential oils, um, in, in the cup and it filters through the air filtration system. So
if you want to put in lavender that day, you can, if you wanted a sage essential oil for, um, you
know, for headaches or anything like that. You can add that. Uh, the unit itself does come with
some, but if you wanted to put your own in there, you're welcome to do that as well. And then it's
got the Himalayan salt block. Salt purifies the air. So if you have somebody who's not feeling
that good, they kind of have a stuffy, stuffy head. It's a nice way to kind of break all of
that up, flush it out and get you on with your day. The, the booth that I had at the, um, in
in the front or at the beginning there, the sauna, it's got a Himalayan, uh, salt purifier
attached to it. So while you're in a sauna, you can break up that mucus and things like that.
We've had one in our office before my daughter was sick. I brought her in, we put her in for
10 minutes. The next day she was good to go. She was at school. So salt therapy, if you've got some
some congestion, guys. So it's got adjustable preset routines. So weight management, I suggest
30 minutes. You really need to be in there for at least 20 minutes to metabolize that fat cells and
really get that results. Fitness, 30 minutes. You can do a 15 minute. It's up to you. You can
customize this. This is your business, okay? Wellness, relaxation, or just a power nap,
20 minutes. It's all programmable. It's TMAX capable as well, so you can program it through
your systems, okay? So this unit, like I said before, this is a tool that you guys should use
or find something that you love and you've got passion for that helps you sell more memberships,
okay? Good. That's it. That's all I got. Lisa, you have something? Do you want this?
Hi. I just wanted to mention that when we brought in our wellness, you know, as you go through the
years, you have clients that were there during maybe their teens and their 20s. And then, of
course, they got busy and then they decided they were no longer a tanner, right? They got into their
40s and even their 50s. And in their head, they were no longer a tanner and have labeled themselves
self as that when we brought in starting with the cocoon and then went heavier into wellness
it was so exciting for me to see some of those clients that I hadn't seen in 20 years come back
but they all became responsible tanners so somebody in their 40s that shared with us why
they weren't tanning anymore because of the aging process just giving them some tips and tools a that
that the industry has changed, be that there's lotions, or we've got ideas on not how to tan
your face, this, that, or other, or just teaching them that you don't need to do 20 minutes and walk
around like an 80s or 90s tanner, which was such a thing then, right? That being a responsible tanner
or what we would like to say is just actually it's UV light therapy. There's a difference between
UV light therapy and being a tanner, but it's the exactly the same equipment. It's the exactly same
thing that we've been offering for 20 or 30 years. It's just putting a different spin on it. So I'd
say that's probably been my most exciting thing is I'd lost a group of tanners and that's thousands
and thousands of people over the years that we had lost that I'm so excited to see come back.
but they came back for the red light every single time they come back for the red light
every single time. So saying that there's red light in the cocoon, but you can turn the heat
down and now you've got more red light with a push of the infrared just to make the red light work
better. Um, but they end up tanning, right? So every single time I do not have one client that
has come in saying that they're never ever going to tan because they are no longer a tanner that we
haven't educated them to being a responsible um not 90s tanner so that's kind of the problem of
having those clients back in the 90s because it was such a different atmosphere right it's about
how much how dark we could get versus on how could we get some light therapy and a little bit of a
glow without looking like that. Yeah. Sorry. Thank you, Lisa. And it goes back to bringing
in units like the Vitality, right? So the Vitality has got red light and blue light in the facial
area. You can control the UV. You can reduce it. You can shut it off. You can increase it.
Does anybody have, yeah, go ahead. I'm sorry. This unit is 25.5. Yeah. Does anybody have any
other questions no great okay we're gonna move on to our next presenter I
would like to welcome our next guest Jacob Jacob from Sunless Inc round of
applause so Jacob's bio I stole this from your LinkedIn just so you know okay
Jacob serves as a business development manager for Nervelle a division of
Sunless Inc overseeing markets in the United States and Canada in his role he
He is responsible for fostering business growth and managing key partnerships.
Jacob will be sharing insight on the WellFit booth, a game-changing innovation that integrates wellness and spray tanning into your salon.
Welcome, Jacob.
Thank you, lady.
Hello, everybody.
How are you all doing today?
Good?
Having a good day?
I've enjoyed sitting here just hearing some folks talk myself.
I rarely get to do that.
um so my name is jacob and i do work for sunless inc we cover the mystic versa oh wait there we go
mystic versa and norvell um all in made all made one building we're all friends now um so i've
talked to a few people already here that i know that have well-fit booths if you have a well-fit
booth raise your hand quite a few already um and with the well fit just just leaning on
what has already been said this morning it is skincare it works with your red light it works
with tanning beds these processes we're seeing a lot because just out of my personal experience of
going to gyms and launching those booths and helping customers and stuff we're combining it
with tanning we're combining it with they just worked out they're going to get in and do this
service and it's the way you explain it and your knowledge to your customers that is really going
to motivate them to do this so with a well-fit booth one of the gallons i'll just go ahead and
with this one gallon will give you about 120 services and for us dollars not speaking canadian
it's one dollar a service five dollar canadian
so well fit is it's it's very skin forward everything about well fit is um it's very
your skin forward taking care of your skin relaying that information to your clients of
why they would use this product what it does for your body how they can combine it with other
services just like y'all were talking about setting up um efts yes thank you man that right
there is going to be another thing to add to your menu of why they come in there um some of the
gyms that i've worked with would we would literally bring the clients in and talk to them
and while they're walking out, just to get them to try the booth while we're there
and explain to them the service, and it comes with, like, the gym membership.
We were signing people over left and right for the gym
or sending them to a person to get signed over just for that reason
of them trying our booth one time, regardless if it's for you have irritated skin,
you have eczema, you have dry skin, different reasons people will use these products
for different things um just like all of our other tannings so this screen is going to be our hydrate
and i'm going to tell you for myself it's my favorite product out of the well fit the reason
for i have extremely dry skin i take sinus medicine i love hot showers like the kind your
skin peels off and this hotel will get there uh so those things are also really bad for spray tans
all of that's bad for a spray tan but this product alone right here is the hydrate is
to help your body to retain moisture it's got trileronic acid so it's literally stronger than
just your regular hyaluronic acid when you feel this product on your skin it's just so
silky and soothing like i love it because i have very sensitive skin um with the hydrate for an
example for me when somebody would come by and i'd be explaining we know our customers right
like if i was your customer i've already told you i've got sensitive skin you already know this
about me this would be something you recommend hey this can help with this this can be something you
can add with a spray tan service so with the hydration what we do is get a spray tan and they
get the hydration after to help with the moisturization because who else had a spray tan
in here before, right? Spray tans naturally dry your skin. DHA, dihydroxyacetone naturally
dries your skin. So the hydration from this alone is going to help tremendous with a spray tan
longevity of the life of it. Me, I'm about a four day guy with a spray tan. And then I see snakes
go. I start scrubbing it off. But for this right here, I easily got a week and that's huge for me.
people that take care of their skin get a week right younger folks normally get longer but the
thing is i mean it's just it's our skin right but with the skin care in this product alone
um has anybody ever used we got a product called amplify norvell does it's my favorite product
norvell has has anybody ever used it before you know the amplify so this right here is literally
about four times the strength of amplify. Amplify is an aloe based product. Uh, it's
hyaluronic acid, aloe and fruit extracts. This right here, the strength of the trileronic acid,
you can feel when you touch the product of how moisturization it actually is. And it's not sticky.
I don't like sticky at all. I work in a spray tan industry and I don't like sticky and that's
a huge problem, right? So with a hydrate, just know this works with other services. Uh, if you've
got somebody that's got eczema you've got somebody that's got any kind of skin issues uh they're
gonna love it like i'm looking at your tattoo when i was at the gym big dudes walking through
and i'm like hey come get in our booth i don't tell them anything about spray tanning nothing
the well-fit booth does spray tans also you can have a bronze and clear and two well-fit options
or four well-fit options or one whatever you want you can set it up how you want to
But when I was talking to the clients, I would switch it up by who that person was.
I didn't know them, but I could look at them.
Hey, like, dude, you need to get in here and get this hydrate.
And they're like, why?
And I'm like, you need to take care of your tattoos better.
They're kind of ashy, right?
And they're like, oh.
And I'm like, do you all know the service for a well-fit booth is two minutes?
It sprays you full body.
It dries you.
You turn around.
It sprays you, dries you, and you step out.
my joke with them was literally it takes you longer to untie your shoes and get undressed
and get in the booth and get out and they're like there's no way they'll come out and they're like
man you were not joking it's so fast so just think with the services these are selling points
because everybody wants a service now why is it not already done and you just told them about it
and if you have questions about this if we've got time i don't
okay she's supposed to keep me on time i'm a talker so with lift so lift is think about it
it's a it's a stimulate collagen production it's what lift does so it's a full body facial
treatment literally it's a collagen treatment so when i look at those customers coming in
you can kind of guide on what people are going to be interested in um your younger younger folks
folks, they're probably like, you know, I don't need this. Myself, I could use it all. It's going
to help with the smoothness and texture of the skin, minimizing skin imperfection. The big thing
with the Lyft is collagen. That's huge. So with the Lyft itself is a blend of natural, effective
ingredients to promote healthy and skin renewal. So when you're talking Lyft, what other piece of
equipment could we possibly have in this room that deals with collagen the ladies that were
coming into the gym that knew about skincare would literally get lift sprayed and then red light
or lift and in tanning beds or hydrating and tanning beds they they were just combining it
left all right today i'm coming in and i'm gonna do hydrate and a tanning bed tomorrow i'm gonna
come in and they tell me tomorrow i'm coming in i'm gonna do lift and tanning bed okay and with
the well-fit booth depending on your option it's a one service full body spray um there are ways to
do just face just legs stuff like that in those booths you were talking to me earlier about your
sessions um do you want to tell do you want to are you good you want me to tell it i think i
remember what you said so she come over to the table and was like three months you've had it
three months and you're already on your second order of products third order so she's averaging
how many how many product well-fit products you have in your drawer two so she's averaging what
240 people a month that's adding this service uh do you do ift not not yet there you go uh but it's
a combination. Is there any, is there other service you offer where they're bit your rec
every day? They do the full service. You just literally, they're coming in for a spa session
at your place. That's what it is. They're getting skincare. They're getting color. That's going to
show the production of visual for us, right? It's like with spray tanning five, you got five on it.
Most people want to do, they want to like an instant. You got the bronzers, right? I want
that some people want the clears where you don't have the transfer to close so with the lift college
and production production with the recover now the recover is gatorade for the skin if you've got
somebody that works out they will love the recover recover is going to help with um replacing amino
amino acids. Um, it's going to help the, um, Lord, I went blank. Let me think. Let me think.
Yeah, it does. Amazing. So when you work out, you sweat and you lose your amino,
you lose your amino acids, your electrolytes, your mineral, um, um, magnesium and potassium
recover, literally helps replenish this on your body. So it's not going to do as good as a normal,
normal your body can normally produce right nothing to that we add to our bodies as well
but it's going to help those people that are in there they're sweating they're working out
and just as the gym sessions i watch daily the people that were like it was cardio day they're
sweating they're running you know they're sweating like crazy and i'm like hit the recover they come
over and do it they're like i just feel so refreshed when i walk out of here like it's it's
It's literally a very nice process that only takes two minutes.
There's not a whole lot of things in our services that we can do that's really that fast that they can feel a difference in.
Am I like two now? Three?
I got two slides. I'm going to be like a minute a slide.
So with the balance, the balance is going to be helping our biomes, our natural biomes, to fight negative bacteria on our bodies.
that's what the balance is for so this is literally like a it's a health
product right everything we're doing here is to be healthier so with the
balance itself it's gonna be really good for the skin to help with those natural
biomes and fight the negative bacteria pretty much on our bodies very soothing
also calm calm is brand new it actually will not be out for about another five
five months. Um, it should be, I think it was, was it Angela five, six months from where through
there, Brandon said that it is to be hitting the shelves. Uh, calm is going to be pretty much like,
um, Elaine was talking about bad day. It's going to be a sensory product. It's going to help you
literally calm. Uh, it's going to help with your just overall. Now it does say CBD on here.
There's, it says a product similar to CBD. There is no CBD in this product. We can't even make a
our product with CBD. Helps reduce inflammation also in the skin. A lot of these products have
ingredients that help with inflammation. So that's a big thing about it, but it's going to be kind of
what piques your interest on this and how it's going to work better in your life. If it's winter
time, I'd for sure do hydrate, right? Summertime, hydrate in Florida might not work good, but if up
here, if it's still kind of dry or cool or something like that, you can use those products
and people are going to immediately feel a difference.
Anybody that has a booth that wants to tell what they do or talk about it?
Quick statement, anything?
I've seen several that had booths.
I'm looking over here because I know there are several over there.
Yeah?
All right.
Well, if you've got any questions, I'll be at the table out there.
You can holler at me and Angela.
Yes?
A prep for the red light?
Yes.
Yes. Well, the, I mean a two minute, they could get in and do the two minute service and get
straight into red light. But, and I would recommend probably the lift where it's collagen
based. But if your client comes in and they're like, I've got dry skin today, like you can look,
I would do the hydrate. Do y'all do, I know several of y'all raised your hands and did
y'all do any combinations? Uh-huh. Yeah. There you go. That does make sense.
it all right uh yeah jacob do you want to talk about the bag of hydrate that will be in the swag
bag that everybody's getting don't drink it it has a qr code on it is not to put in your water
bottle it is thank you jacob can we have a huge round of applause awesome and you did great on
time thank you all right it is my pleasure to introduce our next guest miss lisa that's you
ma'am we're thrilled to welcome lisa from perfect tan she's a seasoned expert with over 30 years of
experience in the tanning industry as the owner of three successful salons come on over lease
lisa has perfected the art of incentivizing staff and boosting employee retention creating
motivated teams and driving business success. Her expertise in building a positive work culture,
rewarding performance and keeping staff engaged has set her salon apart. Today she's here to
share her proven strategies for retaining top talent and ensuring your team stays inspired
and committed. Get ready to learn from one of the best in the business. A huge round of applause
for Lisa please. Hello I'm Lisa. I thought I was in some kind of little room so this is great.
uh i always say there's never a microphone i've never loved so um so i've been in the business
for 31 years um up until i would say maybe about five years ago we would average a staff between
like 12 in the slow season up to 18 in the busy season and now we're sitting at about 40 to 45
people in the last couple years so it's definitely changed my um yeah my role in my job a little bit
um but I still love it and I would say the best part of my world and I kind of think what I want
to take away from Perfect Tan when I retire in the next 20-30 years um is just the hundreds of
girls that have come through the door that hopefully it's our job to send them out a little
little better than they came so um what they've asked me to talk about is just how I keep them so
I do have a couple staff that have been with me um 25 years 28 years a few at 20 years
but the majority of them are uh you know kind of between year five and ten year range and then also
um every year you've got your students that come in and you're just lucky to have them for a couple
couple years and and that's perfect and we love them too so your students whether they be high
school students or university students we love them all definitely in the last few years I've
started hiring a bit younger and really loving that actually loving that I'm their first job
and I can kind of teach them the ins and outs of work ethic and what that looks like and really
enjoying that. Do not be afraid to hire young. They're so multiple and easy to, you know, kind
of get on your team and really work hard. So sometimes I say those bad, they get a bad rap.
Do I click? Oh, geez. You saw me take my arrows on where this right here. I'm like, you saw me
I take my glasses off? Okay. This is something we implemented in that Caitlin wanted me to talk
about a little bit. Years ago, I was getting a little bit frustrated as the team was starting
to grow on just those things of having younger staff. And so instead of being frustrated and
being mad and correcting or always feeling like I was correcting, which still happens,
what we decided to do was implement a rewards problem program and really in a nutshell it was
everything that didn't piss me off so they got rewarded for keeping me happy so obviously oh
this is the rewards they get so I'll tell you a little bit about how they get them so this is what
but they can spend their perfect 10 points on.
You can do it any way you want for how they get their rewards.
So obviously there's going to be some sales rewards,
but not all of my staff are salespeople.
So you want to make sure that you're keeping it a little bit for everybody
so that the bed cleaners can also get some rewards.
So we will have rewards on, big rewards on setting up, we call them direct sun, which is your EFTs, which is the absolute biggest part of our business. So they will get rewards for signing up an EFT, they get rewards for anything that's an Excel and extender, anything that's a lotion over $75, over $100, all of those things, which are easy, you can pick those things.
but also um things like uh a perfect month so not changing any shifts not um not coming in late
because that's obviously where you want them to be but uh when they're you know not changing shifts
not giving away shifts we call it a perfect month if they did um everything the way the schedule was
coming in for a shift early staying for a shift late for us working between the stores uh they
They would get more rewards if they had to pick up a shift at another store.
They would bring stuff from store to store, working in the community.
What would be some other ones?
Merv, what would they do?
I know, sorry, you love it.
I thought I had the other sheet.
Pardon me?
I know, I know.
So like anything that would be community-based,
things that I was getting frustrated on.
And where it started as getting frustrated when I would spend so much time putting a
schedule together that had this person working with this person and, and, you know, I've
got different strengths working together to find that my schedule is being changed all
the time.
But I couldn't keep getting mad because their worlds are, as you know, the most important
thing that has ever happened in their whole entire life.
And everything that they do is just so important.
so instead of getting mad because they were changing their shifts that's okay that's life
but if you didn't change your shift you would be rewarded um instead of getting mad because it was
the same people that were picking up all the shifts i would reward the people that were picking
up the shifts it just literally it was great for them but it absolutely changed my brain so i would
would say this is probably more manager owner based than it would ever be staff based it did
everything to benefit my brain and show up to work positive and happy and and and and but most
importantly it made me happier because I felt like I was rewarding the girls that were making
my life easier because that's really all it comes down to. Um, I say that during their annual, um,
when they get their annual meeting with me, um, their commissions on our, how much they make.
And I have girls, I have a girl this year that made more money than I did it because of, of how
well she does and what she sells. And that makes me so happy to know that her life is different
because of how hard she works to sell to my, to my clients is great, but their wage is how easy
they are on me. How much easier do they make my life? That's how they're, they get their wage
increase. So there's two different things. You make my life easier, right? You become not a
problem. You're great to my clients. I don't have, you know, I don't have corrections or things to
to fix with my clients and things like that. You teach my new staff well. That all makes my life
easier as an owner, as a boss. So their wage is reflected on how much they make my life easier
and their commissions are completely up to them. Sky's the limit. But this is on top of their
commissions, their direct sun contest that we have every year that just started February 1st.
we also have their bonus for our direct sun retention so february 1st to april 30th they get
well they get reward points they also get four points for every direct sun elite three points
for every direct sun all access two points for every direct sun platinum and then i think they
they get two points for upgrading from one to another.
Those points, you know, collect up to, I think, Wendy.
We bottomed out at 100 points, and she got 180 points.
Girls have had trips to Mexico, trips to Hawaii.
Yeah.
Well, you know, so we've got these, and that's on top of reward points.
So the reward points are all year long.
Their direct sun bonuses are until April. Then their retention, because every client you lose
now have to resell to somebody new. So retention, which is the hardest part, is September to
December. That's just straight a bonus on their paycheck. So if we are level or up, which doesn't
always happen. But if so, if we started with, you know, a thousand direct son clients, September
1st, if we still have a thousand December 31st or more, uh, we bonus out, but that's just the
managers and that's money on their paycheck. But so this again, back to this, this is all year long.
Um, I have McKenna just got her third Apple watch. She's been with me 10 years and she's now on her
third Apple Watch. Back in the day when I started it, it was TVs were a big deal. TVs are not a big
deal anymore. Dyson Airwrap is actually, I think we added it to this one. Dyson Airwrap is the
number one thing that girls are wanting to save the reward points for. So a Dyson Airwrap is about
$800. With tax, it's about, what do you think, like almost $1,000 with all the accessories.
so they cannot wait. They work towards something or some of them are hilarious. And as soon as
they've got 20 points in their bank account, they can't wait to spend it. So that's this in a
nutshell. And if you want more from me, I can totally help you on it. Great question. We just
got a new system that does it up until like right now. Wendy, the general manager of the stores,
each girl does their own on a sheet or pen and paper it's each manager's job to make sure that
they're all telling the truth just like when they would check their commissions before I pay them
and then Wendy is the one you would go to to redeem them so I go and buy the product hand it
to whatever they choose give it to Wendy Wendy gives it to them to make sure that those reward
points are being taken off. Yeah. Yes. Yeah. There are good programs out there right now that I think
Sally's going to touch on some good programs. I haven't implemented it yet, but as of right now,
we're doing pen and paper. Oh, cause that would have been really smart to bring that, which is
what I thought I had. That was my bad when I sent this to, to Caitlin. So my apologies, if you want
anything, I can absolutely send it to Caitlin. Yeah. And it definitely, another really big one
when I started it, and it was huge points. You could get two, three, or 400 points was mystery
shoppers. If you guys have ever done mystery shoppers, right? Secret shoppers. Um, that is
a huge one. If they would get a hundred percent on their mystery shoppers, they would get 400 points.
That was awesome. Absolutely an awesome one. So I'm probably running out of time, but that's,
um, that's a good one. So for us, you get your wage, you get your commissions,
you get your reward points, you get your Drexun bonus points, and you get your retention bonus.
And then my big managers get a bonus at the end of the year if we're doing well, which is great.
Oh, did I? Shut up, I did. Oh my gosh, I just did them in the wrong order. Here they are.
Yeah, is this it? Yes. Nope. Redemption, is that? No, is this just redemption? Was the other one
direct sun and this one was redemption. My apologies. The other one was the direct sun
if you wanted to. So remember how those direct sun points that we talked about how many they sell
two, three, four. Um, that was the last one. This is their reward points. My apologies. I should
have put my glasses on. Um, so this is what they can spend on their reward points if you want to
take a peek at that. So then that's where you get your Apple watches again on it, personal products,
um buying points or tanning packages for family is a huge one um airpod pros is a big one another
new one that came out was the the max the headphones max was a big one um so but you can
always start a bit smaller if you want i'm always trying to find new things to do um for them to
to keep them happy. But beyond any money that you give your staff, this new generation,
more than money, they, believe it or not, their rewards and their bonuses and things like that
mean more to them than money does. Side note, I had one of my managers, I literally think that
about half of my staff, if I just gave their paycheck straight to Lululemon and Aritzia in a
gift card, it would be great. Out of 40 of them, I think only five of them pay their own sale bill,
right? It is insane, right? So honestly, it is the rewards and how you treat them is more than
the paycheck. But then knowing that your staff that are with you that need the paycheck, making
sure that they're taken care of as well. But what I have also found with this new generation,
which has been really awesome, is, and I love it, is putting them together as a community.
So also, it used to be that Merv and I would take the managers away on a retreat, whether it be to
Vegas or Florida, wherever the conferences were. And it was one of the girls said,
instead of just taking a few of us away, what if we all went away, but not, you know, on a flight,
right so it started off that we went to whistler we've we've been to whistler we've been to manning
we really it's now our goal just to not be kicked out so um that's always a problem but that has
been amazing for us so um as a quick one with that and then we'll i'll finish up is every year we
call it our christmas getaway eve and we started when it was in october but now just being a bit
bit busier in wellness. Um, we do it more at the end of August, September, mostly because September
does start to get really busy for us, which it never did before. Um, so we want to kind of start
that off, but we all go away, all of us. So whether you have a group of five or a group of 40,
we bring in old staff. So everybody is there. Um, we stay somewhere together, which I like way
better than a hotel room. If you can do that, um, they get all their Christmas presents on
on their bed. So they get their pajamas, they get their swag that has perfect tan on it.
This year they got outfitted with Lululemon and jackets, but we trying to come up with a new thing
every year is always hard. They've gotten so many different fun things over the years. It's all
sitting on their bed and they run like it's Christmas morning to find it. And the new girls
are always so excited and they don't know what's going on. Then we sit and I usually have a
a conference room set up and I think there might, might not have made this slide, but it's literally
like a conference, just like this with Rose. They've got their water and their whatever I
decide to put on there. And they listened to me talk for seven hours, six, seven hours. We have
a lunch and we come back. I always think, what am I going to talk about? Funny. And we start with
with everything that is important to me, uh, important to us as a company, we go into a little
bit of sales. Um, we'll have a, usually a quick manager's meeting the night before because the
managers and I go out and hang out the night before we have a quick manager's meeting about
that. But truly it is the best way to get them completely all yours. If you don't stay the night,
night you will lose the girls to, um, whatever their social is. And then that's what they start
to think about. I need to be out by seven. I need to be out by whatever time, having them stay the
night, waking up in their pajamas. They all make me breakfast in the morning, which is great. Um,
they don't ever want to stop talking ever. They want it to go on till seven, eight, nine, 10 at
night. We bring in dinner. We keep going. We party like crazy that night because it is in
a safe environment where it's just the staff. Merv goes home. It's just girls. They're dancing
around. They are bonding with each other. They would do anything for each other. But I've had
their absolute attention for probably all in 12 hours of not paid staff meeting. It is absolutely
priceless and it sets off our year. You know that everybody is absolutely on the same page.
They've become a team. They know it's an absolute privilege to be there. And it is probably hands
hands down, one of the absolute best things that we have ever done to keep a team tight. And they,
I remember one of the girls had wanted to work with, for me forever, but we have a minimum,
you have to be able to work this many hours, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And she just said,
and she's 23 now. And she's like, I have been dreaming to come to one of these
since I was 16 years old. And she was like, it was really great. It was really great. So
So I just, with the team bonding,
making sure they're all on the same page,
reward them well, but do not forget to check in
because the check in and words of affirmation,
if I'm gonna, that's what I started with,
words of affirmation for this generation
actually means more to them than money every single time.
That's good.
That's amazing.
Okay, thank you.
Awesome, Lisa.
Thank you so much for sharing that insight.
site. You really and truly have built such a fabulous culture. There's a little bit more of
the photos that you have. Yeah. You, uh, you guys do culture so well. So thank you for sharing that
with everyone. Well, that's our morning guys. What'd you think? Yeah. Have you started working
on your actionable plans yet? Okay. Yeah. Good. Um, we're going to break for lunch. We will see,
we're going to resume back here at 1 45. So if you guys can kind of aim to be back here at your
table by 1 40, just so that we can kind of stay on track because we are live streaming and people
are tuning in. We want to try to stay on track as much as we can, but feel free to join your staff.
Um, you can eat in here, eat in there and we'll see you at 1 40. Thank you.
Welcome to the stage, Sally. She's my coffee, my coffee partner too. Yeah. We always have a coffee
happy date. Here you go. Thank you. All right. I get a clicker and do I get a pointer so I can
laser point at Greg? There's a laser pointer too. I can be like, point at him. Hi everyone. I'm
Sally. I've been in the industry for about 20 years. I'm going to go and retire and be one of
Lisa's employees after just watching what I watched. So I want to talk today a little bit
about efficiencies of an owner. So I'm not trying to sell you anything. I'm not affiliated with
anything that I'm going to show you. I'm just going to kind of tell you what's worked for me
and hopefully it'll work for you. The first thing we're going to talk about is Homebase. It is
something that I implemented after COVID. It is a timesheet and scheduling app that you can use
in your salon for free. Okay, so if you are a small business owner and you have less than 20
employees, this app is completely free. If you have more locations you can add on for a cost
or if you have more employees or you want more features I'm going to show you
the first video of kind of an overview of what it's gonna bring for your salon
the volume working oh we'll go back I think so oh no it's not going no one
luck it's the secrets industry secrets I don't need a clicker
okay so we're going to skip the video because it obviously doesn't have any sound so
some of the benefits that i have found um has anyone here ever had a employee not show up for
a shift because they didn't know they were scheduled yeah or they forgot that they were
scheduled that's my favorite i didn't know it was scheduled um so with the employee schedule it
takes me for five to eight employees it takes me about five minutes to write an entire month of
schedules. So what's great about this thing is with home base and with the way that this app
works, it'll actually send a reminder to your employee an hour before their shift. Hey, be on
time for your shift today at this time, which is great. Okay. They can also send you time off
requests on the app that you can then either approve and or decline. So how many people here
here in this room, get about 70 emails from staff saying, I'm only available this day and I can only
work at four o'clock and anyone else, right? With this app, they can actually put in their time off
requests for the entire month, or if they have an actual other job or they are going to school,
they can put their availability in as well. So when you go to that app, it'll actually have a
blank schedule but it'll have all the time off requests and who you can put in and what you can
do for those shifts the employees can then also trade shifts on the app so they no longer have
to send you an email saying hey alana and lily are trading a shift on tuesday and um can you
make sure that's okay they can trade the shifts automatically and you just have to approve them
okay I get a report every single day from home base it is linked to my clover app or my clover
machine which is something that with the memberships make sense you have to be on so with
memberships make sense they always put you through to the clover app and the clover machine so I get
a report based on what my percentage of my sales was to what I actually spent in my time off
requests and everything. So it'll be all in one report. I also get a report daily from Homebase
that has what the time sheets were. If someone was over in time or under in time, it'll actually
send me a report. So that's really good. If you want to pay for the paid version, it will also
remind you if someone hasn't clocked in or clocked out for their shift. And it also sends a reminder
again to the employees. So there's tons of benefits with this app. And one thing that I'm
going to be implementing with moving forward, which I'm just starting to, is that there is an
option to reward your staff. So going back to what Lisa was saying, there's a milestone thing or a
high five that you can just send a high five to that employee for the day if they did a really
good job. Then they get notified on their phone and away they go. The other really great thing
that I've used on this one is the hiring hub. So who here is having problems finding employees
sometimes, right? You go on Indeed, you go on Facebook Marketplace, you put apps everywhere.
Here you put what your job is and you send it out and it'll actually send to all different hubs for
you. And then all the resumes come into that one spot and then you can set up interviews. You can
email them directly from the hub. So if you have multiple salons or multiple locations, it's really
good for the hiring hub as well because it all comes into one spot. Any questions on that? Yes,
Caitlin. So one of the ones that it goes to is Indeed. It also goes to LinkedIn and it does not
go to Facebook Marketplace. So if you are using that as your job kind of hiring, then you'd have
to do that independently. Okay. So we went over trading shifts, that type of thing. They also do
have a communication tool in this app. We have not used it. We use Slack mostly for our
communication. So this is another free app that you can download. We used to have a communication
book in every single salon. I don't know if anyone remembers that, where staff would write
things that have happened. And then I'd be like, I'd go in and it'd be like pages and pages and
pages and pages I'd have to read of stuff that needed to be done. With Slack, our staff can send
send me a message or put it on a channel of what needs to be done. And they get it instantly on
their phone and I get it instantly on my phone. So that is another free app that you can download
for communicating and getting rid of the communication book. Okay. Any questions?
No. Okay. So this is, if you guys want to scan this, you can download the app and take a look
at it. If anyone wants to come see me at any point or send me a message, I'll happily share
what it looks like. With this app, they've also added a checklist portion to it. So who here has
cleaning checklists in their salon? Please everyone put up your hand. So there is a new portion that
just came out this month with the app and it is actually for checklists. So you can have your
checklists in the same app and have them check off who did what. We currently use Trello for that.
It is a free app. So if you want to also write that down, that's a great one. They all integrate
together. The other thing with Homebase, what it integrates with is we use QuickBooks for our
payroll. The timesheets automatically load into my payroll. I approve the timesheets, it loads into
the payroll, I hit pay and it pays them. I don't have to double check it. I don't have to do
anything because I've already checked the timesheets. With this app, you can restrict,
because i know some salon owners are like well they're going to clock in early they're going to
clock in this you can restrict when they can clock in it can be five minutes before their shift or two
minutes before their shift so that you can actually stop the time stealing as they call it from the
employees that are clocking in early before their shift and you haven't noticed it lisa yeah so what
our staff do is they clock in right away when they've realized that they send a message to me
on Slack and I can go in and I can adjust the actual, yeah, while they're learning. There's
also in the paid version, it'll tell them that they forgot to clock in. So you can set a time
of like after five minutes, if they forgot to clock in, it'll set a time for them and it'll
send them like an actual email. Anything else? That's just one. So you can go back in and adjust
their timesheets. The other good thing, if you do the paid version, I believe it's like 20 or $29
a month um you can restrict where they can clock in they have to be within a certain kilometer range
to your location as well so thank you huge round of applause thank you sally you're always so far
ahead when it comes to uh having your finger on the pulse of all the cool things does anyone else
in the room have an app that they're using for their salon right now that is like a must that
that everybody should know about?
Oh, about connect team.
Okay, write that down, research it guys,
put it on your goal list.
Denae, gotcha.
That's super smart.
So like a team viewer app, gotcha.
So what Denae is saying is that she can jump
into her salon computers at any time using like a team viewer
if somebody's struggling or needs help,
she's made sure that she can jump on from her phone
and give them a hand.
I can take over the microphone
they were asking me to be more engaging fine so yeah definitely easy you can use remote pc
but you can also use bnc viewer it's a free app and it allows you to remote in I can remote into
either location either computer and check sales stats I find it quicker than using the
like salon touch app or the software so I can run I can use the printer I can you know do all the
things so that's useful thank you that's so helpful that's what this room is all about today
guys it's sharing with each other learning from each other I mean there's no sense in reinventing
the wheel if somebody's got something really cool that we can all benefit from it it's great to
share. So I am very privileged to be the one to welcome Ms. Michaela Thomas up next.
Michaela Thomas is the National Sales Trainer for Devoted Creations. With a strong background
in business administration and entrepreneurship, Michaela brings both passion and expertise to
the world of sales. Her eight years in the tanning industry from managing high volume salons to
training top performing teams have given her deep insight into what drives successful service
and product sales. Big round of applause, please. Thank you. Wow, that was such an introduction.
Thank y'all. Okay, so my name is Michaela. I'm one of the sales trainers over at Devoted.
And I have worked in a few different tanning salons. I've worked in generally like local
town salons like one in my hometown in New Jersey and then I studied business administration at the
University of Mississippi and I worked in my salon there which we were seeing upwards of like 300 to
400 people a day like which is crazy especially in a small town like that but we were a five-star
diamond salon like I'm sure some of you are here we thank you for that but it kind of opened my
eyes a little bit to see like the opportunity and how, you know, even just working with other
people collectively at the salon. Cause I was a manager, but I always had at least one, if not
two people working with me. So I was able to kind of see how they sold things, right. I sell things.
And then even being a sales trainer and kind of going to different salons and seeing, you know,
just different demographics, you know, what kind of skews that they carry and just obviously the
the personality of all their employees, everybody sells a little bit different, right? And I don't
know your guys' customers, you guys do. So you guys know kind of how you could integrate certain
strategies and how to integrate certain sales and deals and all kinds of fun things that's going to
help build and boost your sales, right? So I will get into a little bit of some sales strategies
that I've kind of seen work, some things that I've talked to other salon owners about, but that's a
a little bit about me. And if you guys see Alex at the booth or hanging out, um, give her a shout
out. She's been killing it on Instagram and Tik TOK and all those fun things, which I will also
mention is a huge selling strategy. So that's kind of why I gave her a little shameless plug there.
So I'll get started. So some effective selling strategies, I wanted to kind of keep it simple,
um, to kind of have, you know, just an easier, a little bit of a breakdown.
down. So having specials, having sales and having loyalty programs. Does anybody include any loyalty
programs or anything in their salons right now? Yeah. So obviously these can look different for
every salon. They're going to look different for every salon, right? You guys, again, you're all
of your customers are different. Your demographics are totally different. Even the products you carry
could be totally different. Social media. Like I said, social media is huge. And I know you guys
are probably tired of hearing this because I'm sure everybody is saying this all the time how
important social media is but this is a lot of how sales are getting across nowadays not even
speaking about tanning but how many of us go on Instagram or go on TikTok and we buy something
because we saw it on there right I literally do that daily that's how I shop um social media is
a new form of Google search right we go on TikTok you know how does this piece of tanning equipment
equipment work, right? You know, we just came out with new lotions, you know, look up Velour
Devoted Creations. Somebody's probably going to have a review about it on TikTok. So this is a
lot of how we're doing sales nowadays. And I feel like if we're not using social media, we're missing
out on a huge part of the industry that obviously needs to be fulfilled because that is what
everybody is on. And then environment, professional image. So again, this is just your salon, of
of course, the kind of things that you proceed out into your community. Megan and I have been
doing a sales training on Devoted on Demand, which is called a sales fluencer, like how to
become one instead of being just a sales associate, right? Because so many people being a sales
associate, that could kind of like steer people away almost. I don't know, does that make sense?
But I feel like this industry is kind of taking a turn, kind of going with the social media part,
we're more influencing people to buy things behind the counter than we are selling them.
Like we're selling them on something, but we're selling them almost on an experience,
right? When I was working in a salon, I sold so much based on like personal experience. And that
sounds bad, but I would almost like talk about myself the whole time because somebody's more,
like, that sounds really bad. Like I just talked about myself, but I talked about myself in a way
that I would, you know, ask questions and, you know, I'm having this conversation with somebody,
but I'm getting to the bottom of the things that you and I can kind of relate on to then influence
you to buy something that I've used because I have a personal experience of it or from it.
So kind of going into special sales and loyalty programs. So I actually have a training that's
about to be uploaded onto Devoted On Demand if anybody goes on there, which is creating
monthly sales, monthly specials, monthly promotions. So these are huge and you can
can kind of do whatever you want with this. So I think having something different every single
month to kind of implement into your salon is super fun. And it's important because it's creating
some sense of urgency, right? So we just got into February. Let's say we're getting ready for March
and we're going to have some sort of sale, right? You have it start from March 1st to March. I don't
know if March ends on the 30th or 31st, but you know what I'm trying to say. So you have it run
for the entire month. And again, it creates some urgency. Make it a really good sale, right? Buy
one, get one green product for St. Patrick's Day or buy one, get one a month off. Something like
that where it's getting people in your salon and it's creating, again, just that sense of urgency
because we know in this type of business, that's huge, right? And this is our busy season. So we
want to make the most of our busy season. And then again, these can kind of be tailored towards
whatever you like. And if you continue to do it, people know that you're going to do it. You don't
necessarily have to tell them what kind of sale it's going to be, right? Switch them up. You don't
want to have the same ones like every January, every February, every March, because then people
are going to anticipate that and expect that to happen. But if again, you kind of switch it up,
create a little bit of a surprise, a sense of urgency, it's going to get people in that door.
kind of going off of that in those slower months you guys see make that your best sales right make
that your best deal something that people are going to want to do in those off months when
they're maybe not coming in but you want them to come in in those slower months so let's do a
really awesome sale on product um you know in the summer months for example we're about to come out
with product launch in september so you know kind of run a sale on product get through your inventory
a little bit so you can bring in all of the wonderful new Devoted Creations products that
come out for product launch. Things like that. Again, people are going to be coming in regardless
because they know that that sale is only going to be for 30 days. So June might be a really slow
month, but if I'm getting a yearly membership and I can only buy it in June, I'm buying it for sure.
There's no way I'm not going to buy that. And if you, again, only have it for one month or you
you have it on just such a ridiculous sale that they almost have to come in. It's going to bring
people in. It's going to bring a lot of revenue in on those months where you maybe aren't seeing
that many people. Same thing with weekly sales, seasonal specials. So I know like Christmas is
a big one, right? Everybody has crazy Christmas sales. Pink Wednesday is a big deal, of course.
So holiday season, of course, we see a lot of that. But again, kind of tailoring things to
the seasons, tailoring things to, you know, certain type of holidays. Like I mentioned,
in St. Patrick's day. Um, may could be like a mother's day kind of thing, but again, it could
just create a bunch of urgency and it's going to bring some revenue in that you maybe hadn't seen
before. Um, and then start a loyalty program with current customers. So this is really awesome
because your current customers are really loyal to you, right? These are the people that continuously
come back. They refer their friends, they're referring family members, and they're constantly
coming back into your business and spending money in there. Um, I know when I worked behind
Behind the counter at the tanning salon, the amount of referrals I would give for like
my nails and my eyelashes and my hair was like ridiculous.
So I was like, so I think I need something with them because I've given 17 people to
my nail lady and now I have no appointment time, right?
So it's kind of one of those things where creating some sort of loyalty program where
these people, you already know that they're coming in.
So give them something.
If they bring a friend in, give them 10% off the next time or 20% off a retail product.
These are just kind of some examples that I made up, but it could be whatever fits your salon,
whatever fits your customers, whatever's going to make the most financial sense for you guys.
Right. Um, but again, bringing, having them bring a friend in, having them bring a family member in
and giving them something super small, like 20% off a product. And it could make it just that day.
Again, it's urgency. They're like, Oh, can I, can I come back and use it next week? Nope.
You have to use it today. Right. So then again, you're building revenue in your salon that exact
exact day at that exact time. And they brought a friend with them. And it doesn't matter if that
friend's doing a single session, something small, the friend's probably going to come back because
again, your customers are your most loyal people because they're constantly, um, you know, referring
your business and they're constantly coming in there and giving awesome feedback about your salon.
And that's the most important thing we want. Right. And then social media. So of course,
this is the biggest one. Um, Alex is in here now. Sorry, Alex. Um, but she absolutely kills
in our social media. And again, we're a business obviously, but we're a different type of business,
but utilizing social media on every part of a business aspect is super, super important.
Um, so it's going to create the image of the salon, the image that you want for your salon,
which I kind of go into next with like professionalism and all of those kinds of
of things. So, you know, if you're going to be running sales or running promotions, post them
on your Instagram, right? We're constantly posting that we're here at the UVLUX show this weekend,
you know, so people know what we're doing. People know that we're out here and we're doing these
things and, you know, we're having an awesome time with you guys as our customers and all of
those great things. So it's one of those things you're going to be able to get the most out to
people, right? The most reach. And then again, adding onto the sales kind of portion of that,
make it a post where they have to share it, repost it, tag a friend. How many of these giveaways do
we see on Instagram all the time? And you're getting tagged by your friend in some like
t-shirt and a hat, right? We see that all the time. And that's important because now my friend
who lives in Tennessee has just tagged me in a post. Now all of a sudden I follow a boutique
in Tennessee and I live in Florida, but I'm interacting with that business because they
made a social media post and my friend is interacting with that social media post.
now I'm interacting right so have these having these posts be able to be reposts and reshared
is super important because you're just going to continuously get your reach out there same with
kind of google reviews um if you guys get google reviews and you respond to them your algorithm on
google is going to go up so like it's kind of like the same thing with instagram we post so much on
instagram so you see us on your feed we post so much on tiktok so you see us on your feed
feed and it doesn't have to be something super crazy, right? Um, it could just be like something
like this, like holding a picture of a bottle. Um, just something that an image you guys can see,
right? You guys bring in new equipment, post about it. You guys bring a new product, post about it.
You guys are here at the show this weekend, post about it, make an awesome, fun post. It doesn't
have to be anything crazy, but again, just constantly having something on there to make a
post so that people know what you're doing. And again, you're constantly just getting boosted on
your feed. And then professional image. So obviously all of us want the cleanest salon
in the world, right? This is super, super important. Having a clean space for you and
your customers to make better sales. So again, this kind of goes hand in hand with like your
customers being super loyal to you. Generally, if I go to a really awesome place, whether
it's a hair salon or it's a restaurant, you're going to make a comment about it, right? You're
going to be like, I love, like if somebody asks you, oh, like what restaurants do you recommend?
and you're like, oh, I love this place and this place. I wouldn't go to that place because
it's not clean or something like that, right? So having that constant image that it's just
everything is great, it's clean, their employees are really happy and they're welcoming and
they're making it a really awesome environment and experience when I walk into their salon
is key, right? We can do all the social media and all the sales we want, but if we don't have
a welcoming environment that's clean and warming and all of these other things, we're probably not
going to make a lot of sales. So it's just really important that, you know, these customers have
brought themselves to your guys' salon, right? They've Googled tanning salon near me. And since
you responded to all those wonderful Google reviews, you popped up as the first tanning salon
and they're there now. And it's, you know, when they walk in that door, it's your job to make
that experience for them, right? And that's what sales is. Sales and all of this is a total
experience for these people when they're walking into your salon. And then having like decor and
and product displays. So we did a bunch of wonderful bag deals with Uvalux, right? And one
of them is the College Genetics Illuminate bag deal. This bag deal is a complete full collection.
And you know, it might be new to some salons if you guys haven't brought it in yet. But even just
something like products like that, that is an awesome display, and it's a full collection could
look really nice on your counter. And again, it's in their face. So when they walk in, the first
thing they're going to see is this full collection. And it's going to make the sale just a little bit
it better because it might make something for them to talk about. They're going to be like,
oh, what's this? And it's not behind you on a shelf. It's in front of you on a counter.
So while maybe you're helping another customer, they're looking at all of the wonderful displays
that you have that aren't behind you that are in front of you or maybe on the side somewhere
where they can go over to it, look at it, see it, maybe pick it up. Usually when things are
in people's hands, they have a hard time putting them back. I do the same thing. If I pick up a
a dress and I try it on, I'm probably going to buy it. I have a bad habit of that. I'm probably
going to buy it if I like it. So I have a bad habit of doing that. So if something is in somebody's
face and you know, they're able to kind of see it and touch it and feel it kind of like the things
we're doing in the other room with products, it's going to make the sale just a little bit better
because again, it's kind of eliminating that first talking segment with them, which is sometimes like
pulling teeth with customers, right? I'm sure you guys can agree. I've had, I worked in a few
tank slants where I was like, perfect. They don't want to talk to me. And I like to talk. So that's
a big problem for me. So having to kind of have that conversation with them can be difficult and
again, can kind of hurt a sale maybe. But if we have some sort of product decor or display of our
new equipment with maybe quick little facts, right? There's all these wonderful ergo line beds here.
If we had just a little quick fact sheet that we could print out and put on our counter,
now we've eliminated a little bit of a conversation with somebody because they've
maybe read it and now they're really interested about it. We have a little product display on
our table with all of our facial products. I've actually gotten a few people that have asked me
if I can email that to them because it's going to eliminate a little bit of that conversation
with looking at all of the facial products individually. They can see it, just what the
product is. There's no crazy facts on it. Just dark DHA, dark cosmetic bronzer, facial moisturizer,
right? Or blue hued tanning accelerator, basic things like that with a swatch. So again, if
somebody didn't know that they wanted that or didn't know that they maybe needed it, now they
have the ability to look at it without you having to pull all five of them down. They're now looking
at it. And again, it's just some little decor that you can add to kind of just add to the aura of
your salon. And again, these can kind of vary with what you want and what you think looks best. And
And of course, I know you guys all have beautiful, wonderful salons and your setups all are so
unique to your salon.
So kind of having that fit your mold and kind of fit what's going to look best based on
when people walk in, right?
Even when we're doing booth setups in here, you know, Alex and I were setting things up.
We're like, okay, people are walking in this store.
What do we want them to see first?
Right?
What do we want there to be a big deal?
That photo booth.
You walk in, you see this big glow light up photo booth.
We want you to see that because we want you to be intrigued about it and ask and take
pictures and all of those things.
So again, little things like that can kind of just entice sales a little bit differently
and it's going to help in the long run, of course.
And everybody, like I said, salon is a little bit different, but you guys can always make
it the way you want to feel like you can fit your financial needs and kind of just tailor
things a little bit differently to your salons.
And if you guys do have any ideas or you guys see things that we've kind of mentioned
that have worked for you guys, please reach out to us too.
too. We love to hear like feedback and just to see that you guys are doing well, because again,
we as a business can't grow if our salon partners don't grow. So that's super, super important for
us. And every time we go to a training, you know, whether it's a salon training or it's something
like this, I always like to hear feedback and, you know, just able to kind of grow because we
can constantly grow if you guys are growing. So I think that's all I have for you guys.
but does anybody have any questions no okay perfect well sure negative social media so like
if somebody posted something negative is that what you mean yeah I would always even if there
is like a negative social media post I would always try and respond to it always try to make
things right because even if you're if you're not responding it could still negatively hurt you but
if you are responding there's still that chance for that little bit of positivity and then again
Again, if you make it right with somebody, you've now made like a different type of bond
with them, a different type of relationship with them that in the long run could help
with a sale too.
And then if you respond in a really nice way, of course you would, they're probably going
to mention that to a friend.
Be like, wow, that business, you know, something maybe happened once, a little hiccup, but
then they've recovered and now I'm willing to go back.
Did I answer your question?
Okay.
Did you have one?
We love to do that.
Yeah.
Always tag us in stuff.
Yeah. Always tag us and stuff. Um, Alex is literally making Tik TOKs as we speak and
reposting on Instagram while we're here. So if you guys have things, if you do take pictures
in our photo booth, please, please, please tag us. Cause we like to see him, but Lisa also likes
to see them and she's not here. So please always tag us and stuff. Cause again, we like to interact
with you guys, of course, cause you guys are our besties. Thank you. We appreciate that.
That's Alex.
We love that. We love that. Well, if you guys don't have any questions, any other questions,
I think I'm good. Thank you. Our next speaker, do we have her in the room? Oh, there she is. There
she is. It's Rachel Harkin. Come on up, Rach. Rachel is a graduate of the University of Wisconsin
with over a decade of experience. But branding is very important. It needs to be recognizable.
It needs to be professional, but it also needs to be cohesive. You have to tell that brand story
story of who you are. If you are a whimsical brand but you have very rigid photos, it's not going to
work. People aren't going to understand it. The other things that you need to remember are your
branded elements. You need to have a logo. You need to have recognizable fonts. You need to have
brand colors and you also have to have your brand verbiage. So when you're scrolling, I think the
the biggest thing that you want to recognize is you don't have to see a company's logo
or their name to recognize who it is. A good example of this is Tarte. You can look at Tarte's
Instagram or any of their ads and it's very recognizable based on the filter or the type
of photo that they're putting up. You don't have to see the Tarte logo and you don't even have to
see their name. So that's kind of what you want to base your social media content off of or even
in just your marketing branding strategies. You want to be recognizable without having to have
your logo shown. So if you see some of our ads, you're going to see that designer skin, she has
her own personality with her ads. She has a cohesive brand. So you don't even have to see
the designer skin logo at the bottom and you're going to go, oh, this is a designer skin ad. I
know what this is. I know because of how the models are dressed and I know how the layout of
the ad is. Same thing with Australian gold. Tells a whole entire story and you could take away all
the verbiage. I could take away the hot bottle and I could take away the logo and you would
still probably recognize that was for Australian gold. Swedish beauty, same thing. And then we've
got California tan. So a lot of what you guys do, you need to be able to tell that cohesive brand
story. And for New Sunshine, we have a lot of different brands. They all tell their own story.
you can recognize designer skin she's your high class girl she she's bougie she's over the top
and then you come to california tan very scientific very clean two totally different brands two
totally different stories and they use different fonts they have a different logo that goes with
their brand and they also have different imagery that goes with the brand now canva how do we put
this all together so you have your branding you have your logo that represents who you are you've
got your fonts that tell that story. You have your verbiage down. You're like, okay, great.
I am going to be the sultry brand. So everything that I say is going to be exciting. It's going to
be sultry. It's going to be soft. How do I put it all together? Canva. Canva is great. Now I will
say this. It is not a replacement for a graphic designer. However, it's very easy to use. And I
You can get pro for like 120 for the entire year and that enables you to do full scale
editing.
It also enables you to get a lot of sounds that the basic plan doesn't have.
It gives you a wide variety and you can make your own brand story through Canva.
So you can do documents, you can do flyers, you can do videos, you can do social media
and you can really make it your own.
You can also upload all of your branding.
you can have a brand package within canva and it makes it so easy you can upload your logos
from whether you got it from adobe or microsoft word or you can even use canva to get your own
fonts and your own logo and you can create it in there you can upload all of that put it in a nice
pretty package under branding and so when you are doing your social media post creations or when
when you're doing your flyers or even videos, you can go to your branded folder, pull everything
into that, and it's going to make it nice after you've designed it. It's going to change everything
for you in the click of a button. It's fantastic. So you would start with a blank, as an example,
just a blank canvas. Do whatever you want with it. And you can go to templates. They also have
an AI feature that you can type in and say, I need fun in the sun and tanning. So it's going
going to create an image for you where it's just going to come up with a template that's going to
have those keywords. Once you have your template, you can actually change it to anything that you
like. So you can also download it with a JPEG, PNG, PDF, depending on what you need it for.
Everything is there for you. So here's some examples of how you can take your blank canvas.
you take three different images that you want you can put it into a different canvas or a different
template and then you can actually change on the side um the the font and the text you can remove
things you can start editing you can erase certain things that you don't want and just from that
blank canvas and that template that you chose from and then you chose you get your branding
and you have your ad and that is all maybe like 30 minutes at most so it's I recommend getting
canvas for canva for you and then other cool features is you're like okay I want this to be
the main photo and I want this word to be the top layer you can go into the layer section and you
can actually move the photo above the font or you can move the font behind and you can play around
around with it and canvas so easy that if you make a mistake just hit undo and you're good to go
and then you can also um you don't have you have a text on there like a preset one you can actually
change it through line spacing or word spacing and you can anchor the font you can unanchor the font
um so have fun with it if you guys get on canva just play around with it it there's tutorials
there's always webinars i definitely recommend using it it's going to be very beneficial for
your marketing strategy. All right. So what do you do next? You have created all your social
media campaigns. You're like, do I just post it on Twitter or Facebook? No. You want to make sure
that you are optimizing all of your platforms. So what you want to do is you want to use a lot
of other resources such as scheduling platforms. Canva has their own scheduling one if you have the
pro version, but you can also use Hootsuite. You can use Later. You can also just use the
meta platform to schedule as well. My recommendation is pick a day, plan out your entire week or even
plan out your entire month and just sit down and do your entire social media strategy for either
that week or that month and schedule it. Because as long as you have a plan, because we get busy
as business owners or even in everyday life, you're like, oh, I can do this tomorrow. Well,
something always comes up and then you've missed posting for the day. So definitely take advantage
of the scheduling platforms. The other item that you want to focus on in your social media are the
in-app features. So we're going to go over the highlights, your link in your bio, any pinned
posts, and your analytics. These are all very important during your social media strategy.
So your link in bio, it helps your customers or your followers know who you are. It can link to
your website. It can also link to your link tree and it can help you cross collaborate with all of
your other social media platforms. If you're on Instagram and Facebook, this is a really great
way to connect them all. You can also do surveys. Your highlights. I love the highlight section
feature. I use it for my influencers. So if I see something that I'd like to know it, they've posted,
I'm like, Ooh, I really like her feed. I can go to her Instagram and I'm seeing, okay, her spring
fashion. So I go to her spring fashion and I'm looking through everything that she has posted
for that year same thing with you guys if you are running a promotion in the spring or if you know
that there are certain lotions that you want people to focus on put them in your highlights
right at the top so people can go directly to them and it's a quick reference guide
your pinned posts mostly you guys aren't going to just be posting one time a week you want to
be posting multiple times a week or even multiple times a day depending on your guys's own personal
personal strategy. So pin post, if you were running a promotion for that week, if it's free
tan week, you don't want it to get lost. So you can pin it right at the top and you're going to
get more views. It's the first thing that people are going to see when they go to your social media
platform. Um, so you can do it as a giveaway. Um, you know, let's make it eye catching, make it
exciting for people to see right away. This is probably your most important tool that you will
will ever use in any marketing campaign is your analytics. You need to have data to back up why
you do things or why you're changing course. So your analytics for social media, it's going to
measure the performance, it can measure your reach, it can measure your impressions, and it can also
measure all of your engagement and also track your followers. You can through the in-app and
through Facebook or Meta or even TikTok, you can collect reports from various specific dates. So if
you ran a campaign for fever, right? You wanted people to buy fever for that week. What I would
recommend is the week prior, what were your analytics? And then for the week that you ran
fever, check those analytics. And then the week after, what happened? Did your engagement go up?
did your engagement go down during that week that you were posting all about fever? How
many sales did you get from that promotion? So with that, you have to have your analytics
because that's also going to help you say, okay, I need to do more of these. I need to do more
reels. I need to do just more static posts. Are polls doing really well for me? What are my
followers engaging with? So make sure that you are always tracking these poll either weekly or
monthly reports. You also have to diversify your grid. Don't just put up static posts because that's
going to get boring for your followers. Make sure you've got reels. You want to make sure that you
have different graphics. You want to have just plain images. Diversify it, but make sure it's
still following all of your branded guidelines. Cross-platform promotion. Huge. So what we do at
new sunshine is if we are running a giveaway, we want to increase our followers and our engagement
on TikTok. So we will run a giveaway on TikTok, but we'll also promote it on our Instagram and
Facebook. We'll have to say, hey, we're having a TikTok giveaway, but in order to win, you need
to follow us on TikTok, like us, share us, repost, but make sure you have to follow us. That is
another way to get more engagement on all of your platforms. You have to also remember you're not
not going to have the same audience on Facebook that you're going to have on TikTok. We all know
that TikTok is a very, very, very different platform. It's more goofy. It's not as rigid
and professional as meta platforms are, but you also need to make sure that you are still
promoting all of your platforms together. The other item is that you have to build a community
through call to action. In your caption, it doesn't have to be this long three-sentence caption.
option ask questions ask you know where are you guys going on spring break it doesn't have to be
anything to do with your business it could be like hey who are you rooting for for the super bowl
today that increases engagement that gets people talking that will help also help your followers
and make you guys seem more interesting and engaging to the customer as well all right so
So that is the end of the presentation. Um, make sure that you are following new sunshine. We love
connecting with you guys. We're always reposting. Um, we are reposting things from today, but we
always want to see you guys with our products and how your tan is going. Um, so if you scan this,
this will take you to the new sunshine, social media accounts and yeah. Any questions? Yes.
Yes. No, you should be actually able to highlight, um, from your static post as well. So, um,
yeah, you should be able to, there's a science behind it. It's a, it's not as easy. Um, but
yes. Yeah. A hundred percent. So, and actually what we're finding is stories are starting to
get more engagement for us. Um, so a lot of businesses are starting to do more stories
because people just don't want to unfortunately the algorithm is kind of wonky right now so um if
you yeah it's always changing so it's not easy guys social media is and I remember when Facebook
just came out and I was like oh this is fun sharing my pictures from the night before um it's not that
anymore so always trying to keep up and I yeah yeah no problem any other questions oh does someone
thank you guys thank you thank you so much rachel huge round of applause please that was
awesome i know it was just a little mini tutorial but it's so nice to kind of look at something and
just kind of hear it um to your question i would say to you do you use chat gpt because it knows
how to do those things so when in doubt i ask i ask my other employee right if you're not
using chat GPT right now and you're struggling with any of this stuff start asking it questions
start asking it and be very direct chat GPT is kind of a crap in crap out situation the better
you get at asking it questions the more comprehensive the information you're going to
get back from uh I have the pleasure of introducing our next guest come on up I have the pleasure of
of introducing miss gina a seasoned expert in sales sorry in sales business development and
merchandising as the director of sales and business development at sun evolution gina has spent the
last 18 years helping salons and retailers maximize their product displays enhance customer engagement
and drive sales through strategic marketing known affectionately as miss gina by salon professionals
across the industry she has a deep understanding of what makes products stand out how to create
and inviting shopping experience and the small details that make a big impact on sales.
Today, she's here to share her expertise on merchandising strategies that will transform
the way you present and sell your products.
Get ready for some insightful, actionable tips.
Please join me in welcoming Ms. Gina Yager-Morris.
All right.
Well, hello, all of you beautiful, amazing tanning professionals.
professionals. Okay, so I only have a quick 15 minutes and I could literally go hours and hours
and hours on merchandising. So today after I'm done, I would definitely invite you to come back,
talk with me. If we don't get the opportunity to talk and spend some one-on-one time, I will give
you my information, but I would love just to help you and go through all about merchandising.
So I know we look at merchandising and we think about, okay, well, it's just the products.
But no, a salon's physical appearance matters.
It matters so much because what is the first thing that a customer sees when they pull
up into your parking lot?
It's your business.
It's the outside of your business.
But it's not just, ooh, they've got dirty windows or why is there tape on their windows
or ugh.
It's the parking lot.
It's outside the doors.
So that's a part of being a business owner
is making sure that your staff
is also looking at what's around them
from the minute they pull in that parking lot.
And you know, I have a bad habit,
but I at least pick up after my bad habit
where you have customers who also have the same bad habit
and they just throw things wherever they want to.
Those things need to be picked up.
Also, if you've got any type of trash or anything like that, that needs to be picked up.
So with that physical appearance, this is the first thing that your customers see.
Also, what is it that you are relaying to your customers?
Do they know that you are a tanning salon?
Back in the day, I used to go and do a lot of in-salon trainings.
And let me tell you, it was so difficult when I would be looking for a salon.
on I popped it into my GPS and I'm like all right I know exactly where I'm going but I can't find
this place like can't we all just have a big sign that says tanning I mean come on because if I
can't find you how are customers going to be able to find you and by the look of your outside are
you pushing away potential customers just because you do have a dirty parking lot because your
your windows aren't clean, what kind of a message are we sending to your customers?
Now, I want you to do me a favor. Let's really look at these statistics. So this is a report
that it was done. So 95% of customers say that a store's external appearance makes their decision
on whether they want to go in and shop. Wow. Wow. Now, maybe some of us need to be working a little
little bit more on our exteriors. Also, 52% say that they avoid a store because of the appearance
of the outside. And 39% say that they will not go into a place that doesn't feel comfortable
and doesn't look like a place that they would normally want to go. On top of that, now what
impacts their decision? Okay, well, 68% said poor customer service, they're never going to come back
and I don't blame them. 53% say disorganized, they couldn't find what they were looking for.
Yep, bye. And 32% say they will never go back if it's dirty. So that all has to do with merchandising.
But now here's something to think about. The next thing we're going to do is we're going to take a
step into your salon. Obviously, all of y'all's salons is really clean, right? Immaculate,
it, right? I would hope so. Because think about this. When I go into tan, what am I doing? I'm
undressing and I'm going in that tanning bed. Do you think that people really want to undress in a
dirty atmosphere? That means that the trash can needs to be cleaned at all times. The rooms need
to be immaculate. It needs to smell fresh. It needs to smell clean. It needs to smell almost
like a doctor's office. Because think about it. The customer is in a very vulnerable situation
situation, and we want them to be as comfortable as absolutely possible. So guess what? You may
have 99 problems, but a clean salon better not be one. So in order to follow this through,
I like to make sure to tell salons that they need to have a checklist. With this checklist,
this is what needs to be done every single day. This is what you expect of your employees.
I have two little boys. They are crazy. They have a nonstop school track mind. And I have to tell
them what I expect of them. This is what I expect from you. If you do not follow through, these are
the repercussions. Your staff needs that as well. Because again, you need to have a clean atmosphere.
And even if you need to do the where's Waldo, we're hiding little Waldos like underneath the
tanning beds or on the bottom of the trash cans, that every Waldo they find, they can add up and
maybe they can use salon cash to get themselves a new product. Maybe it can go towards a gas card,
something to incentivize them. Can you tell I have little boys? I think about everything.
Barbary's not bad, especially if it makes them behave, right? But now let's look at this. What
does this tell you other than, wow, they got a lot of nice products. It shows you a retail
environment, doesn't it? This shows you a retail environment. It draws you to want to pick up,
touch, feel, smell the product. It makes you want to go up and check things out.
And this is actually my buddy Vic's salon. And one thing I love about him, like I'm OCD and I
love to make sure that all of the products are pushed forward. So it's really, really full.
He's like, Gina, I used to work for Dick's Sporting Goods. And one thing that I noticed,
if there's one like taken or just a couple taken and there's an open spot, people are more apt to
come over and be like, oh, somebody just bought this. Why did they buy that? And smell it. Oh,
wow. I really like that. So I'm like, Vic, this is killing me. Like, I just want to push all of
the products forward. He's like, no, Gina, leave them alone. I do this on purpose. I'm like, okay,
well, you know what? My mind just goes crazy. But yeah, I would walk over there too and check it
out. But look at this. So this is the real merchandising fun part about it. So making
sure you have these little pop-up tables in different areas that draws your customer's
attention to. Like look at this cute merchandising stuff that we have. Like seriously, a little
cooler. Yes, it does fit six cans of soda. And that can of soda fits in this cute little koozie
that can you know float along with you but this is just an idea of merchandising and putting a
display up I love one of my favorites is from the tanning studio in Wisconsin and I loved how they
put all of this together and the dollars the dollars is epic how can I save you money check
this out buy one get one for a dollar but now the layout also makes a huge difference so when a
customers walking in, if you've got a table sitting right in front of your actual display,
people are more apt to walk around and not even look at it because it's too cluttered. It makes
them feel uncomfortable. To where if you've got a table, you can move it over in a different area,
separate from your display. That catches the eye of the customer and they're like,
oh, it's over here. And making sure that you have appropriate signage. So a few rules. We want to
to make sure that we're changing up our displays. We want to make sure that we are rotating them.
They should always constantly be rotated at least monthly. You want to show off the wants because
people don't know that they need a product, but they know they want a product. And we want to
look for things that we can group. Like, you know, it's not a grocery store. When you go in a grocery
store, how everything's just, you want to set things aside, things that group together. So
your moisturizers and your body washes have the same flavor. You don't just want all of your
your moisturizers, and then all of your body washes. Put them in groups so that they know,
hey, this has the same flavor. I love this. I mean, and I love like this right here. You can
use simple little things just out of the ordinary extra to really showcase. Like seriously, those
crates, I think they are the cutest thing. And then again, a beautiful display, clean.
But now what are some different things that we can do to draw customers' attention? Well,
Well, I call it the pink flamingo in, or the pink flamingo in the window.
Random off the wall things that catch your customer's eye.
Buy a simple little flamingo, like at the dollar store, and dress it up.
Put a tutu on it, put a feather bow on it, heck, put a crown on it for all I care, little
top hat, but add it to the area so that when the customer walks in, they giggle and they
look at it.
Or take a sign, and signage is not all the same.
please don't don't use a black magic marker and write on a piece of paper that's great for a
lemonade stand but not for your display make sure that you have a clean display and honestly with
that um bogo say maybe it's buy one get one for a dollar or buy one get one free turn it upside
down and post it like that because your customers are going to notice it they're going to be like
what the heck are they doing like did they not notice that it's upside down but it's going to
to draw their attention and they're going to be like, oh, buy one, get one free. And they're
going to walk over and then they're going to check it out. They're going to laugh at you and
be like, they're silly. And then they're going to come to you and they're going to tell you,
because of course they all want to tell you what you did wrong. So sweetheart, I love you so much,
but did you notice that your sign's upside down? Oh my goodness, Karen. Yeah, I did. I actually
did that just to draw your attention and get you to look at it. Did it work? Yeah, it worked. Ha
ha ha, Karen, I did it on purpose. So never, ever expect your customers not to touch a product.
How do they know they want it? How do they know they need it if they can't touch it?
I mean, it's like going into a clothing store. If I can't try that on, I don't know how it's
going to look. I mean, I tried on a couple of pair of pants at the mall yesterday. I loved them.
They were adorable. Once I put them on, I was like, oh no. And then I saw something in the
the window and I was like, I can never pull that off. I'm like, yeah, I'll try it on. That's what
I bought. So if they can't touch it, they can't feel it, they can't smell it, they don't know
that they need it. They don't know that they want it. So maintaining that atmosphere and drawing
attention is what really is the key to merchandising. Another thing that I love to say
and love to do is think about it. When you go into a store and you're looking around,
what is it in that store that draws your attention? What is it that made you want to
go over and look at something? Then stop for a minute. Visually, in your mind, figure out what
was it that drew me over there? And then take that concept and do it in your salon. So all of
these huge retailers across the board spend millions and millions and millions of dollars
on merchandising and figuring out exactly what's going to draw your attention. So utilize them and
all the money they spent figuring it out and do it in your salon. Am I good on time? Okay, perfect.
Another thing that I love to do and I think is really fun is how many of you in here have actual
window displays. Nobody has actual window displays that people can like literally look in and see
your salon. Okay, perfect. So with those window displays, obviously you want a clean atmosphere,
but you can do fun, crazy things. Like maybe it's a stuffed teddy bear, wear in a tutu or like even
do a summer theme and have like products built up by it. And as people drive by, they're like,
Like, what in the world?
Oh, I didn't know there was a tanning salon there.
And they sell body care products?
Become the one-stop shop for any and every customer to walk in.
Become that bath and body works place.
We have so many amazing skin care products that aren't just for UV tanning in our industry.
Benefit off of that.
Work with that.
Build displays.
I mean, we all hear about the pop-up shop.
like, you know, you've got a little, you know, store popping up here, popping up there,
create that same concept within your salon. And with merchandising, of course, I'm going to put
the, you know, focus on products, tanning products, body care products, but there are also other
things that you can do. You know, maybe you have a little pop-up shop of swimming suits when it
comes summer. Maybe it's a little pop-up shop of eyelash stuff. I know that UVLUX has an amazing
brand that actually helps your eyelashes to grow. And I'm not going to lie, I use it because I need
a little help with my eyelashes. Like I've only gotten them added in once and I love it, but it
kind of bugged my eyes and I would have to drive over an hour to get it done. But these are little
things that you can create and do a display that draws your customer's attention. But the biggest
thing about merchandising is you must have a clean, cleanly atmosphere. You must be able to
walk in and not be like a kid in a candy store where you don't know what's going on. Have a lot.
Obviously you want to have more than three of each product. Because if I walk into a salon and I just
see one of each product and it's all kind of, it's a beautiful display, that doesn't show me a retail
buying atmosphere. When you go into, say, a clothing store, even those special niche boutiques,
they have multiple of one item, right? They don't just have one item. It shows it's a retail
environment. Okay, questions? Yes, ma'am. Oh, my goodness. Well, if you want to run a successful
successful business, while this is going through, you suck it up and you clean it up.
Because I can tell you right now, and I know it sucks and it's not,
maybe it's time to think about a different location. Because at the end of the day,
right now, all you are doing is driving away customers and you're losing money. I know it's
a big investment to move the salon, but we have a lot of, I agree with that as well. And,
but I would think about moving that might drive away your customers though too
oh you have to have testers
so what I've had and god bless our clients but they use the entire lotion prior to going into
the bed yeah and this happens I don't know if it's just us or me or they come and they'll use
the entire like a lot of pumping of the moisturizer because they think the moisturizer
so then i would hold it back and keep it so they can't reach over and grab it and then you just go
to everyone oh my goodness when you're done tanning when you come out can let me get let me
give you some pumps and moisturizer and then what they thought it was a brand new bottle
no make sure you're putting tester this is not a testing
take advantage to go into the bed and i'm trying like i've tried what you're saying to put it out
Okay. So I would offer you, please come and talk to me at my booth and let's brainstorm together
how we can move the culture of them touching and dabbing stuff up. And if anybody else has
questions, please come to my booth. I absolutely would love to talk to you and spend that time
I'm with you. Awesome. Can we give Gina a round of applause? Thanks, Gina. Oh, yeah, the clicker.
Thank you. Thank you. Okay, our next speaker, Steve Gilroy. Steve Gilroy has been a dedicated
leader in the tanning industry since 1982. Can we give him a round of applause for that?
Steve began his career as an electrician, wiring tanning salons before becoming an owner in
Calgary. Steve has owned locations in Calgary, Winnipeg, and now West Kelowna. As one of the
first FabuTam franchisees, Steve played a key role in shaping the industry's growth in Canada.
His passion for the industry advocacy led him to help establish Provincial Tanning Associations in
2002, later co-founding the Joint Canadian Tanning Association to unify these efforts
efforts at a national level. Steve has been instrumental in educating insurance companies
about the industry, helping develop a comprehensive insurance program tailored for tanning salons.
Since 2003, Steve has served as the Vice President of Smart Tan Canada, where he helped create
Canada's National Tanning Certification Program. Everybody put your hands together for Steve.
Steve. Thanks for that great intro. There we go. Okay. So I'm going to do this quick because
I've only got 20 minutes and Caitlin doesn't think I can do it in 20 minutes.
I agree.
Okay. So how many people here are members of the JCTA? Fantastic. Good to see you all here.
So I just wanted to introduce some of the people that are here. Actually, most of the
The board members are actually here today.
I mean, we're missing two from the east, which is pretty good.
So we've got Sherry Buckle, our president, and Prairie.
Doug is here, industry advocate.
I can't see Nick or I can't see Merv, but they're here somewhere.
So, but I'll move on from there.
So these are the people that support you.
You should be supporting them.
So that's, you know, they're fantastic people to work with,
and pretty much everybody's here right now.
so where's the click there we go um again these are all of the supporters and i always want to
thank all of our salon members because you wouldn't do this this whole association is
designed for you um we control what happens and on the board uh yes we have industry advocate
members but we have the main vote um just wanted to let you know what our budgets are like
this is where we spend our money here's what we're all about we've always this
has always been our mandate and make sure market to Canadians educate to
governments media relations keeping our members inform and funding research now
the government part we've done a really great job here and you may not know that
or not but in the UK they're inundated with articles about how bad indoor
or tanning is. When's the last time you saw a really bad article about us? This is what we do
behind the scenes. And some of the people that have worked through it were like Nick and Doug.
I mean, we've been at meetings all over the place with governments. We don't do that anymore because
they've actually started listening to us and talking to us when we need to be talked to.
Now, the biggest thing we ever we did back years ago is get everybody united. So now there's a
a world group that actually works together with the suntan association of the uk the european
sunlight association the american suntanning association two people put this together gary
lipman and myself the uk uh chairman and we now have this world library that has 23 000 pieces
of information about our industry we have probably the biggest library for for uv light than anybody
else. This is something we just did this year, which we sent a letter to the WHO and IARC
to ask them to start talking about the benefits. Let's get a balanced message out there for the
WHO. Just so you know, the WHO is actually doing a benefit risk assessment right now.
So the biggest thing that I've always believed in is find you guys a good insurance policy
policy and make sure that you've got the coverage that you need. Sometimes it sounds like it's too
much, but when you get a complete burnout of your salon, you really want a good policy because the
payout is much better than it will ever be without that. So just if you're interested in getting a
price, just give me a holler or you can phone BrokerLink direct, but they have operated it since
since 2020 and they keep continually giving us replacement costs not depreciated costs and if
you don't know the difference come see me at the table i'll give you an explanation of that because
it's a phenomenally different amount of money um the jcta is always about please tend responsibly
the more the governments understand that we want to teach people how to do this right
the more they leave us alone just so you know the governments really didn't want to even touch us
until the Canadian Cancer Society went after it.
So just keep teaching the right way.
So a friend over here is going to talk about Google,
so I won't talk too much about it,
but we have found that Google is probably the best marketing tool you can use,
and the reason why is you can drive them straight to your salon.
What we do is drive them straight to our consumer website, tanresponsibly.ca.
and these are some of the stats that come out on it so our marketing campaign this year
is really just what we've done year after year because you have to continually put it in their
heads how good you are and how you how you run your business so we just continue on with what
we're doing with vacation pre-tanning and lifestyle make it a lifestyle make it a weekly
routine to go into it for a suntan uh sunburn prevention i always believe in that i mean we
don't get lots of good results on that because they don't really it's really funny because they
don't like negatives they love positives and that's when you find that they drive them into
our websites spray tan is always good at the wedding time of the season so that's why we do
it in may to june okay keep going these are just some of the ads that we run um we really push the
pre-tanning and we have to get people to understand that they need 30 days to get a pre-tan none of
this three to four sessions and thank you very much i'm i've got a tan like that's not true and
this is a carousel ad that we're running on our tan nation page which is our consumer page for
facebook and we just it's just a way for them to get to our website and then just having fun in the
the set so google's this this to me is the most important thing all the different ads that we are
running are specific to specific time frames in the in the year and but at the same time i believe
that if we can leave them an impression of us they'll remember us and we find that happens
with our direct google uh direct links into our website so again videos that and now we've you
You know, we don't use a lot of static anymore.
We use video.
I mean, that's the way of the world.
And this is our tan responsibly.
The thing that I always believed in is I'm here to drive people into your salon as a member.
So that's what we do.
So every page has the closest three salons to them.
And that's my website.
That's my salon in Kelowna.
it so what you you know you need to still promote yourself inside so promote some of the the
benefits like to me the biggest thing we have to stop everybody thinking is is vitamin d supplements
are the same as sunlight they aren't they're not anywhere close to it if you just believe in all
the spectrums of light that we're doing today like blue light i just heard about yellow light now
now, where they're going to bring out yellow light. So there's blue, red, infrared, all of
these different combinations. That far exceeds what you take from a supplement of vitamin D.
And that's also why you start to find out on the research that they're doing with supplementation,
it doesn't do as well when you see it on a roundabout way of sunlight and how that is.
to me vitamin d deficiency is a sunlight deficiency that's all it is embrace the sun
i've got a couple of books i'm going to give away on that you should read this book it's
unbelievable we were part of the sun the sunbed section so it is written by us but you're not
supposed to tell anybody that okay so then we have their salon website where you can grab all
all the information you need as a member.
You can put in anything to do with the regulations
if you need information.
I always, please, so many people tell me this.
I don't want to, I didn't want to phone you.
I didn't want to bug you, Steve.
And I'm just like, bug me.
That's what I'm here for.
That's my 41 years of experience
and talking to some of the best people in this industry.
I'm here to help you.
If you need help on an ad,
can I get away with that, Steve? And it's just like, I'll tell you whether or not you can actually
get to be able to promote that. This is a new piece of research and it's amazing piece. And
all I want to tell you is, is it, it's now telling us that using the Solarium reduces your risk
of cancers and gives you longevity. Nobody's ever said that before. Okay. So it, these are the
the pieces that we have for you if you want them and use them. But if you're going to talk about
anything, just make sure you've got your backing and you know what you're doing and what you're
saying because there are things you can and cannot say. The next piece of research, this is all about
how vitamin D is different from the sun than taking a supplement. And when you start reading
this kind of stuff, you understand why the research is working for vitamin D, where it
would be working if they used uv lights so we also held so australia came out with a new
new position paper and we're now pushing to get health canada to recognize that the darker your
skin is the more uv light you need and this came from australia so what we're trying to do is make
sure that they keep up with the information and we're and we're continually educating health
Canada as well because yes yeah if you ever want to know why it was the reason why is they didn't
have a strong association to defend themselves this is why we actually created the world group
is because now we can actually if something's happening in North Ireland and it is sorry in
in ireland we can all get together and help that fight okay because it's one country at a time that
they try and do this stuff and if you listen to what australia actually said and this is the
our opponent saying it we never thought we'd ever get that and they got it because there wasn't a
strong fight and we actually helped the australians when you see the interview you should go on their
website because it actually shows the interview that was with the association there and why they
didn't why they knew they didn't win you know i see like how integrated like ublex is with jcta
right like we hear so many like gyms just putting people in for maximum time for their first time
tanning and now yeah and then these people are damaged and then and then they're never going
to become clients of ours because they're never going to want to tan ever again so we're selling
these gyms the equipment and to people that don't know what they're doing and then it's caused and
then it's causing stress on all of us because we will never retain those clients especially
the younger ones so here's what we tried to we're trying to do right now in the last two years we
actually created an insurance policy for gyms with tanny we're trying to get them in into our
way of thinking um and i think this and we've had these discussions for years
you're talking about a client card but that's what we're trying like
Do you know how we changed the industry in the tanning?
Is we created an insurance policy where they had to have training.
No, but what I'm saying is we've just created this insurance policy,
and we have actually a telemarketer actually phoning gyms now.
And once we get policies sold to them, then they have to have the client cards.
they have to have the because we have no authority just as the government doesn't even want to do
that um so the way we do this is by by making sure we have something that is worth being part
of and that's part of that's the reason why the insurance works so well for us is is that we're
able to that's the hammer and i hate to use that word but that's the hammer that makes them do
training certifications doing client cards and making sure they're controlling the time
and we should have been doing this 20 years ago but i never thought the tanning that tanning would
go into gyms so hard um yep yeah yeah and i you know i think this is where we have to realize
that we need to continue through that but i always found that the gyms that was a sideline to them
but it's no longer a sideline anymore this is a profit center they only saw it as a way to sell
another part of a monthly membership now they look at as a driving force as making as a profit center
so that's a whole different thing than what it was before so i'm getting a i'm getting going to get
about a two minute warning in about a second here but the vitamin d society basically what that is
is an avenue for us to send information out okay because if i say something positive and i'm up
from the tanning industry i am there's like really you're trying to make money from me
well the vitamin d society was set up for an exact problem as what the dermatologists have done
they set up their own little associations and make it sound like it's coming from the science
what we're trying to do is make sure that people understand the importance of all of the uv light
part so three years ago we transferred most of the funding to uv light instead of just vitamin d
so when you see this one this was probably the biggest piece of research we did and proved
everybody wrong that you can use the sunbed to make vitamin d now they say oh that's the wrong
way to make it so they can no longer say you can't make vitamin d from a sundae so these are
some of the things that we're going to take and look after and make sure that the vitamin d the
sunlight message is getting out there and nitric oxide is the big thing right now um which is all
about cardiovascular health so and that is helped through uva light not uvb light so when you're
doing any of this kind of stuff what can we say what can't we can't we save you can save all you
want to do you can say anything you want on your personal page but you got to watch your salon page
because all you really want to do is share the information and just share it through don't add
information about your bed or whatever unless you've got scientific research to prove this
leave that out just share the information if i got time i'm going to share a little story about
a gas station thing I did. What happened? So these are some of the things that we're going
to actually be doing and we continue to do and we need to continue to promote the benefits
and not the sunburn. That's the key to the whole thing. And what you don't realize is seven out of
ten people still tan, but they tan outdoors. What if we just brought them indoors? Seven out of ten?
I only want 10% of that 7 out of 10.
It would double my business.
So I want to tell you a quick story
because I probably only have one minute left.
It's 30 seconds.
Okay, I was at a gas station filling up my tank
and a guy pulls up behind
and this service station actually will fill your tank for you.
And the guy says, no, no, I'm okay.
I'm making vitamin D as I pump my gas.
I could not believe that.
So we know the vitamin D message is out there, okay?
Okay. And thank you. Thank you for all your support. If you want insurance, give us a holler
and we can help you. Thanks so much, Steve. Everybody, a round of applause. So we're going
to take a quick break now. So if you guys have questions for Steve, grab them in the lobby.
We're going to grab some coffee, some refreshments and be back here for 335. Thanks so much, guys.
get my husband and my son's attention all right i think we have a few filing back in are your
brains exploding yet what's up do you have all kinds of new ideas are you filling out your goal
sheets there has anybody got anything written on their goal sheets yet yay yay maybe no are y'all
still awake okay just checking okay let me see those foam fingers in the air can you give me a
a phone. Can you give me a phone finger? Yeah. Thank you. Yes, yes, yes. There we go. There's
some excitement. Okay. We're refreshed. We've had our coffees. We're ready to go. We're going to get
into some really cool stuff. I'm really excited right now to be introducing another one of my
awesome friends and coworkers. We've also been together for many years. She's just getting
getting herself a little timer set up. So today I have the pleasure of welcoming Rachel Hodge.
She's our marketing manager here at Uvilux. With a passion for innovation and digital solutions,
Rachel has been at the forefront of leveraging technology to drive business growth and enhance
customer engagement at Uvilux. Her expertise in marketing, brand strategy, and cutting edge
technology makes her the perfect person to discuss how tools like Tagbox can help businesses
streamline operations improve customer experiences and maximize digital presence presence get ready
for some valuable insight on how to use technology to build and grow your business please join me in
welcoming rachel hodge big round of applause great thank you leanne so thanks everyone for
attending today i wanted to take 20 minutes today to talk about tagbox and this is going to
to revolutionize your marketing platform. Just from a show of hands, how many salon owners manage
their own social media right now? Okay. And how do you find it? Exhausting? Awful?
Yeah. So last year we hired a social media and communications coordinator and she has been my
saving grace. Let me tell you, having a dedicated staff member just on socials is life-changing.
I can go on vacation now and not even turn on my socials. So I just want to give a special
shout out to Selena right now because I know she's watching at home and she is a huge part
of all of the beautiful marketing pieces that you see on the table. So let's give her a round
of applause wait okay so I'm just gonna grab the clicker and there's three up
here so I'm not sure which one let's just okay there we go so I just have a
little intro here I don't want to miss any features because there's lots of
them so what is tag box and why did we choose it so it's our new AI power to
a marketing portal that is also known as a digital asset management tool. That's DAMN for short.
And it organizes all of our marketing files. As you know, at Uvallux, we carry a lot of amazing
products. And we just want to make it easy for business owners to have just one login where you
can access exactly what you need and when you need it. The beauty of Tagbox is its tagging feature.
This makes finding assets easy, whether it's for your social media, in salon
signage, promotions, sales fact sheets, or more. We think you're going to love how
easy it is to use. And if you do not already have access to our new marketing
portal, just ask your dedicated UVilux rep to give you access. You will receive
an email invitation to join and our marketing team will also be making sure
everyone who is joining us today will receive an email invitation as well. You
may have never heard of Tagbox and that's because it's still very new. It's
still in its infancy. It's only about two years old and let me tell you when I say
I tested a lot of damn systems, it was a lot. Almost about ten. So there are a lot
of cool platforms out there, but what I was looking and what our team was
looking for is the efficiency. Okay, how easy it is to navigate the system,
download files, does it upload any kind of format, and just again navigating the
and simplicity of the platform itself. So with that said, their development team
continues to release new features every month. This means it only keeps getting better.
And I actually communicate with the owner of Tagbox. You know, check him out on LinkedIn.
He's great for receiving feedback. And anytime I have a question or a suggestion on how to improve
the features, he is very responsive. So again, that's kind of nice working with a smaller
platform because it's it's great to just have that one-on-one communication. So
our UVilux marketing team updates our tag box every week. So we're constantly
adding files from our brand manufacturers who work really hard on
creating the social media graphics. Okay so think of tag box as your toolbox. Just
just for a show of hands, who is using a digital asset management system or platform right now?
Okay. So I just want to open up the floor. Um, what are you using? Where are you keeping all
of your graphics and your posts and the content that your team creates, you know, of your, your,
your beautiful product shelves, your equipment, how are you enticing customers into your salon?
on? Instagram and Facebook. Okay. And do you have like an album on your phone where you keep all
your images? Okay. Great. Okay. Unfold, Mojo. And do they have like a calendar, scheduler?
No. Okay. So with Tagbox being a toolbox and having multiple workspaces, the nice thing is
that you can actually create your own workspace and keep all of your internal marketing files.
So whether that's the sales fact sheets, the product images that you want to share with your
team. It's really a collaboration tool. Um, just as an example, this event, we are going to have
like probably a hundred at least of videos and photos. All of our staff are on a shared photo
album right now. So where are we going to put that content on our tag box? And that is a private
internal album for all of our staff to have access to. So it kind of, you know, you think out of the
the box. It's not just for social media. It's really like a training tool, keeping all the
sales fact sheets and product information. So the beautiful thing about Tagbox is the AI-powered
filter system. So when you upload an image, it's going to detect what it is. So we have created
manually some custom tags. So whether it's type of format, collection, brand, the year that it was
added, the type. So whether it's sunless, beauty, tanning, spray tanning, you can really create as
many filters and tags that you would like. And now for downloading. So you can download, you know,
single images or multiple images say you wanted to download a whole collection of
a brand you can do that with literally control select all download so it's
going to save a lot of time so I'm just gonna do a quick little live demo just
to show you the home page this QR code is to sign up for tag box now again we
We can send an email invitation for you to join our tag box.
We do have multiple workspaces, so depending on the brands that you carry, you'll be invited
to that specific workspace.
So your reps know what you carry, and then we'll get you added as well.
And it's also desktop and mobile friendly as well.
So you can even create content on the go or upload images on the go.
Okay, so that was just a little sneak peek of a campaign I'm going to talk about, but
but I just wanted to show you the quick little demo here.
Okay, so this is what the homepage looks like.
And then you'll see on the left
are the different workspaces.
So we also have collections.
So right now I'm in the Sunless Beauty Collection.
Okay, so I'll just navigate here.
At the top there, those are all the filters
and you can easily search for anything as well.
and then we have collections who has tried take box great and what do you
think yeah yeah well the nice thing is you can add a team member as well like
for if for those who do have us a staff member that do socials they can play
around with it but okay so you guys saw a little teaser there of a campaign we
we did for Blue Monday. And UVilux really wanted to bring the sunshine this winter to all salons
across Canada. So we use Tagbox as actually a workspace on where we kept all of them. Oh,
I did. I did not. I'm sorry. I'm just on a test demo login. But we do have a workspace
space for all of the blue Monday. And that was just a little real that, I think so. Oh, there we
go. Thanks. Yeah. So we did a marketing kit for salons and it's official national sun bay or sun
bed day is an annual thing. We actually got approved by the distinguished national day
calendar. So we submitted an application for National Sunbed Day. And from nearly 30,000
annual submissions, only about 20 are chosen. And our application was one of them. So thank you to
the salons who helped make this happen. Good job, everyone. And I did just bring a sample. I don't
know if you saw our crewnecks. Elaine has one at the back as well. So we hijacked Blue Monday,
January 20 20th and we wanted to turn the blue to the bright so it was all
over socials we sold out of our crew next we actually just did a reorder
because we want this to keep going all winter long and here's the yellow one as
well yes so it says stay close to people who feel like sunshine and Elaine says
you are the sky everything else is just the weather so we really wanted to
create a positive movement. And it was really designed to help salons promote the feel good
benefits of sunbed sessions. I don't know if it's if Steve is in here. But we did consult with the
JCTA and we wanted to make sure that everything was approved. And this campaign was really just
about good vibes only. We weren't making any medical claims. We weren't talking about, you
know depression or sad or any of that we actually had customers come in and write why they tan on
mini little whiteboards that they held up and it was just amazing to see the response and all of
just everyone just coming together and really uniting this country so thank you everyone and
we hope that you'll participate next year if you didn't get a chance to this year awesome thanks
Awesome. Okay. So before I get into our next presentation, I just want everyone to stand up.
Okay. Grab your phone, Google your salon name so that it shows your Google business listing.
and I want you to look at how many reviews you have, okay? If you have more than 10,
stay standing. If you have less than 10, have a seat, okay? If you have more than 30,
stay standing if you have more than 60 stay standing if you have more than 80
stay standing if you have more than a hundred stay standing more than 130 more
than 150 okay I feel like we're doing an auction right now what number are we at
Dave yeah more than 150 stay standing more than 200 stay standing okay sorry
253 Sunseekers thank you Sally round of applause everyone great job so David is
going to talk about Google and just a reminder all of these presentations will
will be available. If you would like a copy, including Sally's video that unfortunately we
couldn't get the audio to work for Homebase, just email marketing at uvalux.com and we will send
you a copy of the presentation. Okay, David, it is my pleasure to introduce you, a seasoned
marketing professional with 20 years of experience. David is the founder of a successful digital
marketing agency that has served hundreds of clients across five countries. With a deep passion
for technology, particularly Google Ads, David has developed expertise in driving business growth
through digital marketing. David is also an avid outdoors enthusiast, having spent significant time
in New Zealand, and this winter marks his first in Canada since 2010. Currently based in Ontario,
he embraces any opportunity to visit the West Coast.
Today, David will be sharing his valuable insights
on how to leverage Google Ads
to effectively grow your business online.
Please join me in welcoming David Bonham Carter.
This clicker is the one.
Hey, everybody.
Long-time nerd, first-time tanner.
Quite literally last week.
So I've been working with Uvalux for, what,
a couple years now?
Yeah.
Yeah. And so that was my exposure to it. This is actually the second time I've actually
seen products in real life. I always just look at them on a screen. And so it's cool
to be here and meet every one of you. And it's great to see people who have a whole
bunch of Google reviews. Google My Business is something I'm a huge nerd about. Google
Ads is one of the primary things I do, but Google My Business is free. And you can do
it yourself. You don't have to pay anybody for it. So I think it's something that a lot
lot of people should know about and be active about. Sorry, I normally talk too loud. I was
holding that a bit further from my face. I was just saying that Google business listings are free
and a very, very effective way to put your business at the top of a Google search.
When you search something on Google, there's three specific competitions that happen
instantaneously. The top section is reserved for ads. You buy your way to the top. The second
section is called local search which is completely independent and that's populated through business
listings and then below that is organic websites and the way you rank on that is what people
try to charge you too much money for and call seo um don't do it uh well maybe do it sometimes but
don't pay what they want um so you've seen that a million times and so the you pay for the top and
normally a bunch of money it's an auction so you're paying what people are willing to compete
against you for but below that is the business listings and what i guess that's me have a good
day guys um so um ranking on google business listing let's look at a slide um isn't rocket
science uh the factors the one of the major factors is reviews and the quality of the reviews
is just as important as the quantity of them.
But there's a whole lot of space in there
that you can give Google information about your business
and be indexed.
And that's the stuff that most people don't do.
And so we're examples.
People make decisions about service providers
in about a split second.
They look at you.
Do you have more than 10 reviews?
Is it a two-star?
I'm going somewhere else.
And so that first impression really counts. But after that, the information that you can fill your business listing with, such as products, it lets you list products and services, but it lets you put a photo on products. You don't have to put a price tag. You can put as much descriptions about each product as you want. You can list your services as products and put as much information as you want in there.
there. The reason to put all of that information in is because they index you. So who's ever done
a search in Google and Google answered your search with a business listing and said, this business
listing talks about the question you answered. Anybody ever seen that? One person, two people,
three, four, five. Yeah. The rest of you aren't paying attention because they do it.
And so by filling it with information about your business, you can be the answer that Google gives
to some people's questions it's and so the reviews that were talked about earlier by
Michaela are super important as are the replies to the reviews you don't have control over what
people write in the reviews you have a hundred percent control over what you write in the replies
to the reviews so as opposed to saying thanks so much come again if you wrote a paragraph
about what they got and your business well you're feeding it a lot of information to be featured
next time. Oh, that's not what we want. Sorry about this. I'm just going to pull this out.
My apologies. Yeah. It's a Mac. It might not go. It might be lost. Yeah, there we go. Ha-ha.
So this is what I got when I searched tanning salon Surrey just now. So when you search your
business, it might come up like that. If it does, it means nobody has ads in the area. Oh,
oh, it's 146. I thought you had 246. Sorry about that. I got a number wrong there. If you do have
ads in your region, it's going to look something like this when I wrote plumber in Surrey. So you
can see those top ones up there are Google ads. So we can put that, we can write whatever we want
in those copies. We can put whatever photos we want in there. And then underneath it, you see
where the business listings are. If you link your business listing profile to your Google ads
account, you can come up first. They show ads here as well. It doesn't negate your organic
ranking. So if you're ranked first and you have ads, you're two out of three spots and they
basically can't go anywhere else. Cool little hacks. Oh, we're in the wrong one here. So this
is Glow in Fort Worth, Texas. They have 525 reviews. They also listed a bunch of their products,
but without it. And then you can see their responses to it. Interestingly enough, down here,
or somebody oh this is questions and answers so this is the actual only hack within business
listings so you can ask questions on the front end of business listings not on the back end so
as the admin of a business listing well you can ask questions and it comes out like that and says
owner looks kind of stupid if you ask a question and then you go and answer it so i'd recommend
sending the link to your business listing to your friends with some scripted questions
and maybe spread it out over a week or two keyword heavy and then you can go in and answer
with a paragraph everything in questions and answers is indexed by google just like the reviews
this is the only cheating there this is the only cheating there really is but it's worth doing
cheat uh oh down here this is really funny so glow uh the only reason glow has positive reviews
is because they offer free months to remove any negative comments i'm not saying you should do
that but um the uh the the comment was made earlier what do you do about negative comments
and everybody knows that there's terrible people out there
and if they make them look like they're a terrible person,
they're going to know.
If you screwed up, own it and fix it.
But in the reply to them,
you're not actually replying to the person who wrote that review.
You're replying to everybody else who's reading it.
Screw that person.
They're probably not coming back,
but the people who read about how you responded to that complaint might.
This is a post.
They made it in 2023.
uh 2023 within business listings there's a function to put up fancy pictures and put in a
bunch of copy if you're putting a special on your facebook page or a blog on your website
should go on your business listing too it's not that hard it's a place to put it ever in the
business listing so the business listing management dashboard is just in the chrome window um and then
it says posts one of the little icons you click on posts and it's like is this a sale is this a
a deal? Is this just general information? Let's put a bunch of words, a picture. And yeah, so if
you have content you're putting out, put it in there as well. The other thing is photos. Everybody
knows photos. The easiest thing to do is to just get customers to upload photos with their reviews.
If you're doing it yourself, you can put them in. You can also put in 30 second videos. So that's
pretty cool too. And if you're looking at someone's business listing photos and you're scanning,
they actually live play videos now. And sometimes they'll live play videos in the thumbnail when
when you're looking at the business listing on a phone.
So this stuff's changing all the time.
And unfortunately I know way too much about it,
but it makes a difference.
And so this is just the business description.
So that's basically top to bottom
on Google business listings and how they can work for you.
And it's free and it's one of the three sections
that you're competing for
when someone makes a search on Google.
So you should do it.
I highly recommend it.
So now the next question is,
who in the room runs google ads hands up google ads for their business one two three four five
six seven anybody of course you guys do you won the reviews so under 10 um has anybody run google
ads before and had them be a terrible flop and some agency took too much of your money
yeah totally that happens all the time marketing agencies are terrible the um that doesn't make
Google ads ineffective. And so for what everyone in this room does, there's two utilities for it,
driving foot traffic and driving traffic to your website. I don't know if people here in this room
sell things on their website, but there's two different types of campaigns. You can drive foot
traffic to the business or you can try to sell stuff online. They're distinct. The two most
successful campaign types these days are search campaigns, which we saw earlier when someone
types of word in you have keywords that you target you have ads that you show when they come up
and this newest well it's not new they made it about two years ago but it didn't work for the
first year but it's called performance max and this is an area that i think has a lot of utility
especially to this product market the product or performance max takes search ads so you still have
your display headlines as well as your descriptions and everything else but it also encouraged well
Well, you have to upload photos of portrait, landscape, and square aspect ratios, as well
as videos in those exact same aspect ratios, which is a huge pain in the butt to get good
quality assets in three aspect ratios.
The trick is you can take your images and turn them into slideshows, and then suddenly
it's a video.
I mean, videos are better, but if you don't have them, the slideshow is about as good
as you can get.
The reason that they get you to give them to you in multiple aspect ratios is because
is they target people across all properties
that Google has access to around the internet.
So if you're reading a news website
and you're seeing display ads,
Google can put them there.
So someone Googles tanning salon near me,
you don't click on the search ad,
but then you go and read some news
and you're bombarded with display ads.
You open YouTube, played the video in front of you.
And the really great part about this type of campaign
is they are heavily AI driven.
So you can target demographics
and then you let Google go
and you say you want to maximize conversions.
conversions. And if you have conversion tracking set up, it looks at who is the most likely people
who convert on your ads, and then it only targets them and can deliver real value. It knows when
someone's in the mood to buy what you're selling, because AI is creepy, but it can make you money.
If you haven't set up Google Ads, or if you're not running them anymore, Google will give you
$600 if you spend $600 in two months. So that's pretty cool. So that's $10 a day.
I, your cost per click is going to be different in each one of the product markets. And so I can't
tell you what your clicks will cost, but if you do spend 600, which is 10 bucks a day, you'll get
600 bucks back on everyone's table or on your workbooks. Who's got their workbooks. Everybody
grabs their workbooks right now on the second page on the back of it. There's a little QR code
on the paper. Yeah. If you scan that QR code, you're going to get taken to a fancy landing
page that Rachel built because she's awesome. If you write your name and email in there and
submit it, they're going to pick someone who gets to win some help from me for nothing.
That's pretty cool because I'm awesome and I make people money. So yeah, click on that QR code
and put your name in there and one of you will win some help. We're just in the process of sort
of developing a package to support salon owners so i'd definitely be interested after we get out
on break when everyone starts having some delicious beverages to hear from all of you
in terms of what you guys see as your biggest pain points in terms of digital marketing communication
and we can incorporate that into the strategy that what we're going to roll out in terms of
ways that we can support all of you it's just getting started but it's really exciting i'm
I think it's awesome.
I think this is really cool.
And so, I mean, we do Google ads.
I do Google my business.
We do paid social.
I don't do organic social because I can't talk in your brand voice, but I can take your
brand voice and put really, really targeted money behind it and make you money with that.
But there may be other ways that we can help you that I haven't even thought of.
So I'm just learning the product market and how you guys do business.
So I'd really like some feedback on how I can help you kick ass.
I think that's about it.
This one?
Oh, it's the other computer.
We probably don't need that anymore.
Well, does anybody have any questions?
Yeah, nerdy questions for the digital guy.
Anybody?
So if you're on an iPhone, point your camera at it,
and it should select it, and you tap it, it'll bring you to the page?
No?
Yeah.
If you're on Android, you've got to open Google Lens, which is a pain.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I haven't updated Android in a while.
Yep, that's what I do.
I do.
So I got a bunch of business cards on the round table over in the corner.
My email is really hard.
It's dave at easyads.ca.
E-A-S-Y-A-D-S dot C-A.
My phone number is 613-276-EASY.
That's not a joke.
It's the first time I got to tell people that.
I don't tell people that yet.
And you're live.
Oh, yeah.
Hey, everybody.
If you email me, I'm going to make you fill out the QR code.
I can email you the link if you want,
because it would be way cooler if she paid for me to help you
than if you paid.
But, yeah, I'm happy to answer anyone's questions
when we're done here.
Send me an email.
Probably not a text until we're friends.
But, yeah.
Yeah, my pleasure.
Oh, these things too.
Thank you, David.
Everybody, round of applause for David.
Okay, a couple things.
Okay, before we go into that,
this is on everybody's table.
I want you guys to take a minute, scan it, leave us a review,
both West Coast and East Coast, everybody listening right now.
We are going to pick the best review, whoever's got the best review.
Add photos, write something witty and funny and amazing,
and we're going to do a draw for some crew next,
one for each West Coast and East Coast, okay?
Okay. So take a couple minutes and scan this and give us a review. It wasn't until David kind of
pointed this, this out. We need to do a better job at this too. So we're going to be asking you guys
to do a lot of reviews for us. So we appreciate it. Thank you so much. Um, now before we end here,
um, anybody here using a loyalty program? A couple of people. Yeah. Yeah. There's loyalty
programs out there. So I'd like to talk to you a little bit about that. We've got the vendors
coming up that they're going to go through each program. Manufacturer cashback programs
are an excellent way to maximize your bottom line, right? We're in this industry because
we've got passion for it. It's fun. It's exciting. But at the end of the day, it pays our bills,
right? And our goal is to maximize our bottom line. So I always say and suggest to salon owners,
planners pick a program that works best for you and build your bottom line this is free money
free money use it sitting on the table for you grab it the other thing i want to mention to a
couple housekeeping things before i uh pass the baton over back to gina is we've got caitlin's
holding it up in the back it's our touchdown card this card needs to be filled out and put
put in the ballot. Um, if you still have yours, if you guys could, uh, quickly do that, sign it,
uh, give it to Kate. She can make sure that she gets it in that ballot box for you. Okay.
Perfect. Okay. So without further ado, I'm going to welcome back Gina back to the stage to go
through her cashback program. Welcome Gina. Hello. Hello. Okay. Oh, one more click. Okay.
Okay, so here at Sun Evolutions, I can't really say that we really push, push, push that loyalty
program, but I will tell you it is a program that is great for a salon that carries around 75%
in our products. So that's going to be the Supreme Tan, the Snooki, the Hempz, the Pro Tan,
the Fiesta Sun, the Beauty with Light, any of those products. If your salon is carrying 75%
are around about there, you have the opportunity to receive 10% cash back. Obviously, as you build
more and you are carrying over 75%, we can work out and we can do a 12% cash back for you.
But what it is, is it's free money. I take care of everything on my side. So you say, you know what,
we really do. We're at like 65% Sunny. And you know what, if we just increase it by 10%,
we could get be getting money back so you sign up for the program and I take care of the rest
so what I do is basically I work with uvalux and at the end of the year and it runs all year it's
November 1st through October 31st so a year-long program so November I'll bebop to uvalux and I'll
be like hey guys I need the purchase reports on xyz salon xyz salon xyz salon and then I take
take care of it all. I go ahead, I pop the numbers and you get a check. So all you have to do is
basically sign up and just be around that 75%. On top of that, you're going to get a little bit
more TLC, tender love and care. You're going to be able to utilize us more so when it comes to
trainings and request trainings and things like that. Obviously, I can't bebop over to Canada,
you know, as much as I would like to, but I'm definitely able to work via webinar or record
something for you. And what I found that works out a lot better than even like a one-on-one
webinar is a recording because you guys sometimes have the issue with employees and they can kind
of filter in and out quite a bit. This way you always have that training specifically for
whoever's new coming in or even a refresher for the staff that you currently have.
So that's pretty much it. Just round 75% and you're going to get money back.
And when she asked how many of you in here have a loyalty program, I'm pretty sure like,
I mean, I got a Walgreens card.
I mean, I got, there's all kinds of loyalty programs that I'm on.
So, okay.
Then I'm going to quick hand this over to my girl and she's going to tell you about
her loyalty program.
Okay.
Hey, hey.
All right.
So like I said earlier, I'm Mikayla.
I'm one of the sales trainers over at Devoted.
so we're going to talk a little bit about our five-star program and kind of the things that
you guys can benefit from it um all righty so our five-star our five-star diamond program our
form looks a little bit like this and this is going to be our online form so this is super
super easy to fill out um and then it automatically just goes to our support email so we've been
trying to make it say like receive but i promise if you do it we receive it once you hit submit
it. And all we ask for is like your contact name. So like who would we, who we would want to be in
contact with, whether that's your salon owner, manager, you know, who was ever kind of doing
your orders and things like that. And so our program is going to have two different program
back incentives. So you can get 10% cash back and that's going to be, we just asked that you carry
75 of our products so that's devoted creations ed hardy tanovations all of those good things
and then you can also get 17 cash back if you do all of that and then including the advertising
which is going to be the social media portion so we just ask that your social media blast um you
know have all of our logos those kind of things on them which we do provide that for you guys
um same goes along with all of social media alex like she's been with me she um does a bunch of
social media posts and we upload them to a google drive that you guys all have access to so that you
are able to you know use our post we want to make sure that everything is easy for you guys to kind
of get that cash back incentive you guys don't have to do anything your reps do everything for
you you just make your purchases and then you get that money back um and this is kind of rebate
season right now. So this is a perfect time to talk about that. And our program does run from,
um, October 31st to November 1st. So it's a full year. And, um, once you, the year is complete
and all of your purchases go through, it goes through your UVA Lux rep, and then they send all
the information to us. And then as all of those come in, your rebate checks go out kind of as we
we receive them. So that's a little bit about our program. Yes. Um, I believe they are getting sent
out as we speak. So they usually take about eight to 12 weeks. I want to say processing time, you
know, once we receive them. And again, that kind of just goes into how we receive them. Um, depending
on kind of when we get them and then they all have to be processed. No, no, ma'am. So usually
Usually, too, once you sign up, you're in it.
I believe you guys probably ask them to do it every year, right?
The sign-up form.
Yeah.
Don't you guys usually have them re-sign up every year?
Oh, okay.
That's why I thought so.
Yeah.
Once you're in our program, you're in our program until, but we obviously would not
want that.
Yes, that second part.
So 75% of what you carry on your shelves would be our products.
And we don't ask for full exclusivity except for the social media portion.
And that's because if you have customers that like other brands, of course, we want
want you guys to be able to carry them so that you can accommodate all of your customers so no
all right yeah and if you guys have any other questions you can always like come get my card
and we can chit chat about it excellent thank you so much i appreciate it everybody round of applause
next i'm going to introduce jason this is your first time up here so i've got to give you a
little bio oh that's okay here okay so jason brooks the global vice president of sales with
Australian Gold with years of experience and leading sales growth, brand expansion,
and customer engagement strategies on the global scale. Jason is a true expert in helping build
and maximize your business. Get ready to learn how you can take advantage of
the Australian Gold Co-op Program with Jason Brooks. Welcome.
Thanks, Elaine. Whoa, that's awful. But thanks, Elaine. Yeah, I've definitely been jealous of
everybody on the microphone today but all right so um i got a quick question shark tank is that
a thing up here i feel like okay shark so my name is jason brooks the new sunshine i'm now going to
present to you my pitch on our program um but or like jennifer garner for a credit card commercial
but i want to ask you guys how many of you in the room are part of the new sunshine premiere program
all right so i've got a lot of opportunity in the room fantastic so how many of you have a credit
card that you utilize for your business or your personal lives to gain points to whether it's
vacations uh you know gifts for yourselves etc perfect so we use those gift card or we use those
credit cards to earn more for ourselves why are we not using our lotion brands that you carry in
your salons to earn more on your business so you can put more back into your pocket or your
employees pockets with new sunshine we are the leading manufacturer of indoor skincare products
we have been for almost 40 years around the globe we are such brands as elaine mentioned
Australian gold, designer skin, Swedish beauty, JWoww, California tan. With our program, it is
100% exclusivity, but we allow you to put your money to work for yourselves. For example, I just
met with a new group that just signed Premier this past year. With our co-op program, you earn 15%
cash back. Use our logos on any of your printed materials. It could be your t-shirts, your business
cards, your websites, but that 15% is from your purchases. So if you purchase, let's just say
$10,000 from new sunshine products from UVLUX within the year, you have $1,500 that you can
claim in your expenses that you've spent on advertising. So long as you have used our logo
in your advertisements. And I don't want to see designer skin and then your salon name.
it's your salon and designer skin or Australian gold what-have-you very
simple to implement and use in that program now again there's a lot of great
products out in the marketplace but the big benefit of being a hundred percent
exclusive with new sunshine is you're getting consistent training consistent
messaging but also consistency in our products and the investment that we make
in our testing that goes along with that to you the UV Lux team makes it very
simple for all the information with all of our brands and everyone that you've
met with today to gain access to our images and logos. But I know too that they do an excellent
job on providing other social media tools and things that you can use to drive more traffic
into your business. And that's a key part of our loyalty programs with all the brands and
manufacturers. But with that though, again, it's the partnership and whether you are 100%
exclusive with New Sunshine or you are following with everybody, we're here to support you. And
we would love to help you see how the benefits of being 100% exclusive will grow your business.
But even if we can gain 25% of your shelf space,
we would love to do that and have that opportunity.
So Jess Snyder partners frequently
with the team up here at UVilux.
We are all here to help you grow
and help the UVilux team grow as well
and we look forward to that in 2025 and beyond.
So thank you guys for having us here.
But if you're interested in the Premiere program,
stop by and check us out.
Or we have a QR code at our booth.
You just scan it, sign up,
and we'll get you 15% back in this new year.
So thank you guys.
Oh yeah and so we've got this fancy not Swarovski not anything you know not too
fancy you're you're not gonna need a bodyguard for this touchdown knockoff
purse but you know Taylor Swift will have a more expensive version tomorrow
okay so sorry for the slot employees are in the room next door that don't get a
chance to win this but we're gonna draw a special name now let's which of which
premiere has been with us the longest I feel like it's over in this group who's
been a premiere longer than 10 years right here anyone longer than 10 years
15 Elaine do you have an idea this is gonna take you all right I'm just gonna
I'll just draw it I don't know I'm just like just draw it let's let's move on
all right sorry I am in between you and an open bar so are you ready tailgate
Should I put that QR code by the open bar so you can just sign up for your program there?
All right, that sounds good.
All right, perfect.
All right, the winner is Rachel.
Yes.
Can we make it like the Grammys?
No.
Okay, the winner is Spa 6 and Wellness, Heather.
Is it Dranel?
Dranel, Heather?
No.
All right.
Thank you, Uvalux.
What's that?
Oh.
She has it.
thank you thank you so much isn't that a wonderful sparkly bag it's amazing okay so before we break
for our tailgate and uh refreshments we've got some prizes to give away are you guys ready for
some prizes yeah rachel why don't you come up you can pick them leanne's gonna write them down
all of the prizes today guys are actually right over here and a couple at
the back so we're gonna collect them if you're a winner come grab us after the
event and we will box them up and make sure you get them if you are flying and
they won't fit in your suitcase that's okay we'll ship them over to you okay
let me just grab this and then Rachel okay the first one is compliments of
sunless ink got Norval Oasis airbrush spray tan system and your solution to go
with it and the winner is Karen from fabutan 66 is Karen here did she leave
she gone did she have an employee here Karen you should have showed up okay
Kay, Carrie, um, Gavin, Carrie Gavin. Thank you. Congratulations. We're, we'll collect that for
you and give it to you before we go. Okay. You're welcome. Okay. The next one is the devoted
creations, cooler and swag items. Got some Lululemons, a sweater, Lululemon fanny pack.
pack. And the winner is Michelle Brueggemann. Holla. It pays to listen to the Google guy,
I'm telling you. Danielle Smith. Counting. Congratulations. You'll collect your prize
after. Congratulations. There you go. Okay, next. Sun Evolution Starter Kit. Look at this
variety pack we've got two so we'll we'll uh draw for the first one island tan megan congratulations
yep now we'll do the snooki intro kit platinum glow britney congratulations okay the luxury
intro kit and the winner is glaze tanning grace congratulations euro bronze oh congratulations
the protein okay so steve gilroy's got a smart tan online certification and a mark sorensen book
we've got two of them uh glaze congratulations i don't know what that says naked beauty bar
naked beauty bar spa six lynn congratulations oh thank you okay new sunshines under the lights
pack you've got all of your restored products your ct body by ct and then you've got that
wonderful bag the winner is anytime fitness jill jill you in here jill you missed out on
estella mccartney bag okay next cute phoria aurora i love the support in this room
congratulations heidi you won the you won the pack yay glow and glow okay an australian gold
intro pack and the winner is egyptian gold trish congratulations and the swedish beauty
intro pack goes to Sun and Spa Alex yay we'll ship it to you it was worth the
trip to BC see designer skin intro kit this is a huge kit like even putting it
together I'm like this is a good value Sunseekers Sally congratulations the
The California tan intro kit.
Hollywood sun, Chelsea.
It pays to bring two people.
That's it.
That's all we've got.
We do have one more prize.
Yeah.
I got them all.
Yeah, you're up, Kate.
We're efficient over here.
We're waiting for this tailgate.
Want to come up?
Final call.
Okay, Kate, what's the...
All right.
What are they winning?
Well, I'm so happy you asked.
The prize for this is our door prize,
and it's $250 to a Ticketmaster e-gift card.
So you can go to a football game, if that's your jam,
or go to a concert.
So did you do a good spin, Spinaroonie?
Are we new?
No, I'm just kidding.
Yes.
They would win it.
And then we'll just scream it out to them there.
Totally.
Start manifesting.
Danica, work!
You are the next contestant on The Price is Right.
Congratulations on your prize.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations.
That's awesome.
And she was videoing it.
That's the best.
Guys, I want to thank you so much for joining us.
I hope you guys all enjoyed this format.
I know that we did.
Let's continue this conversation with our tailgate party.
And thanks so much for all of your support over the last year.
Once again, thanks to our vendors as well.
we'll give them a round of applause they put a lot of time a lot of energy into
this and they traveled really quite a distance thank you